[Zene]
köszöntök minden kedves hallgatót a
következő vendégem simon károly aki
informatikus egyetemi tanár és egyben
közéleti szereprő is beszélgetni fogunk
az információs korszakról erről a
hihetetlenül változó világról a
mesterséges intelligenciáról kell-e
félnünk tulajdonképpen a mesterséges
intelligenciától vagy pedig öleljük
magunkhoz közel és tapasztaljuk meg hogy
hogy milyen lehetőségeket hordoz magában
kérlek tartsatok velünk és jó
szórakozást
kívánok köszöntelek téged a műsorban én
alig várom már hogy belevágjunk
mindenféle izgalmas témába ez a
digitalizáció az it stratégia ez az
informatika világa amiben mind a ketten
benne vagyunk te is informatikus vagy és
én is informatikus vagyok és szeretnék
beszélni konkrétan hoztam pár gondolatot
amit szeretném hogyha körbejárnánk
megvizsgálnánk és elmondanád te is a
véleményedet
úgyhogy köszöntelek a műsorba sz
üdvözlöm a kedves hallgatókat és nézőket
kezdem egy gondolattal emlékszem pár
évvel ezelőtt amikor leültünk
beszélgetni most ezt elmondom ezt a
gondolatot a hallgatók kedvéért tudom
vel neked már elmondtam de azt hiszem ez
jól kontextusba helyezi hogy miért is
akartam beszélgetni a mai nap
veled ha megnézzük így az emberiségnek a
korszakait akkor azt látjuk hogy ilyen
nagy korszakokra lehet leosztani és az
első nagy korszak az a a
vadászgyűjtögető korszak volt amikor
mindenki vadászott és mindenki
gyűjtögetett és hogyha akkor
megkérdeztünk volna valakit abban a
korszakban hogy milyen lesz a jövő tehát
íy az emberek szeretnek fantáziálni
arról hogy milyen lesz a jövő és
izgalommal tölti el de félelemmel is
folyamatosan őket hogy milyen lesz a
jövő akkor ők olyasmit mondtak volna
hogy egyre nagyobb családok egyre
nagyobb területeken vadásznak és
gyűjtögetnek és nem ez lett a jövő hanem
egy teljes korszakváltás történt a
mezőgazdasági korszak jött mindent
leváltott amiatt mert az aki
mezőgazdasággal foglalkozott annyival
hatékonyabb volt hogy egyszerűen lem t
hogyha ha ha nem tanultam meg a
mezőgazdasági korszakbeli eszközöket
használni és akkor persze itt is
feltevődik a kérdés hogyha ugyanígy
megkérdezünk valakit a mezőgazdasági
korszakban hogy milyen lesz a jövő akkor
akkor azt mondja egyre nagyobb családok
egyre nagyobb
területeken mezőgazdasági
tevékenységeket folytatnak de nem ez
lett a jövő hanem jött egy újabb korszak
és teljesen leváltott mindent ez az
ipari korszak volt és mindennek
iparosodnia kellett a mezőgazdaságnak is
egyszerűen azért mert valak aki annyival
hatékonyabban tudta használni a gépeket
annyival hatékonyabb lett a munkája hogy
hogy nem volt kérdés hogy hogy ez egy
tehát mondjam úgy hogy erőszakkal is
leváltotta ez a korszak az előző
korszakot és akkor persze ugyanz a
kérdés hogy ha megkérdezünk valakit az
ipari korszakban hogy milyen lesz a jövő
és akkor kedves hallgatóknak mondom hogy
az ipari korszakból jövünk mi itt
székelyudvarhelyen de az az egész
világunk az ipari korszakból jön és és
megkérdezzük hogy milyen lesz a jövő
akkor akkor nyilván a megpróbáljuk
meghosszabbítani így a fantáziánkban
hogy milyen lehet a jövő hát egyre
specializáltabb gépeken egyre
specializáltabb munkások nyolc órában
fognak dolgozni de nem ez lett a jövő
hanem jött egy újabb korszakváltás ez az
információs korszak ami mindent
leváltott ugyanis az információs
korszakba információs korszakbeli
eszközökkel annyival hatékonyabban lehet
dolgozni hogy hogy muszáj volt az
iparnak is
informatizálódnia és akkor elérkeztünk a
nagy kérdéshez az információs korszakban
magunkat megkérdezzük hogy milyen lesz a
jövő és egy kicsit szeretnék beszélgetni
egyrészt a múltról is tehát hogy erről a
váltásról ami az ipari korszakból most
az információs korszakba tesz át minket
mert mert ez bizzony egy egy drámával
jár tehát amikor azt mondjuk hogy egy
korszakváltás történik akkor a mélyén
amikor a hétköznapi életünkhöz közel
kezdünk el gondolkozni akkor azt látjuk
hogy ez rengeteg félelemmel aggállyal
munkanélküliséggel veszéllyel
változással jár és és egyszerre tehát
egyszerre izgalmas és egyszerre
félelmetes hogy milyen lesz a jövő és
emlékszem amikor pont erről
beszélgettünk akkor azt a szót
használtad hogy ha a régiónk nem tud
változni ha nem nem ismerjük fel ezt a
bölcsességet hogy valójában tanulnunk
kell és hogy hogy ez az információs
korszak nem csak hogy itt van hanem
robog és dübörög é és mindent levált ha
ezt nem ismerjük fel akkor rezervátummá
fogunk válni és emlékszem hogy ez a szób
elj égett a fejembbe ez a rezervátum szó
mert tényleg egy szóba összefoglalja azt
ami ami amitől tartok én is nem akarom
hogy a környezetünk egy rezervátummá
váljon úgyhogy kezdjük talán ezzel a
kérdéssel hogy mit ért ezt el rezervátom
alatt pontosan miért is foglalkoztat
téged ugyanúgy ahogy engem is ez a a
digitalizáció ez az információs korszak
és hogyan látod ezt a képet amit úgy
most úgy elmondtam neked ezt a példát jó
hát először akkor reflektálnék arra hogy
hugye milyen kontextusban használtam én
akkor ezt a
rezervátum kifejezést ugye a fejlődésnek
a kontextusában nagyjából abban a
kontextusban amit nagyon szépen te is
felvázoltál és és nagyon igaz az amit
elmondtál amiről talán nem esett szó a
bevezetődben az ennek az egész
változásnak az üteme és jelen
pillanatban egy olyan korszakban élünk
már egy jó ideje amit elég egyértelműen
a tudományos és technológiai
fejlődés határoz meg és ennek a
fejlődésnek a az üteme az az nagyon sok
szempontból nem lineáris hanem
exponenciális nagyon-nagyon gyors tehát
ezt nagyon egyszerűen úgy tudnám
megfogalmazni hogy hogy mindaz amit amit
elmondtál vagy vagy még egyszerűbben
gyakorlatilag a 20 században a tudomány
és a technológia annyit fejlődött mint
mint tulajdonképpen az emberiség
történetében azelőtt összesen és a 21
században már nagyobb volt a fejlődés
mint a a 20adikban tehát ez egy
rendkívül gyors exponenciális fejlődés
különösen igaz ez mondjuk a az
informatikára de egyéb más területeken
is érződnek hatoson hatások ugye az
informatikában van egy egy már elég régi
megfigyelés is ami ezt a bizonyos m
törvény ami ezt már a 60-as években ugye
a az intel egyik alapítója megfogalmazta
ugye eredeti formájában azt mondta ő
hogy ugye a
legalacsonyabb árú
[Zene]
komponenseknek a komplexitása minden két
évben megduplázódik vagy másképp
fogalmazva gyakorlatilag az egységi
felületre
elhelyezhető tranzisztorok igen és
ezáltal ugye a logikai áramkörök
bonyolultsága is tehát a gyakorlatilag
és ezáltal összefüggésen a számítás
kapacitása az minden két évben
megduplázódik ami egy rendkívül gyors
exponenciális ütemet ír le persze hogy
ennek megvannak ilyen formában a fizikai
korlátai de ha egy picit általánosítunk
ezen a igazából megfigyelést mert nem
törvény tehát már hosszú évtizedek óta
megállja a helyét és hog egy picit
általánosítunk rajta és azt mondjuk
mondjuk hogy az egységnyi áron
előállítható vagy megvásárolhatóz ás
kapacitás duplázódik meg minden két
évben akkor az gondolom hogy ez még egy
jó ideig még nagyobb paradigmaváltások
nélkül is meg fogja állni a a a helyét
sua sumárum egy rendkívül gyors fejlődés
hogy egyszerű példát hozzak amit ami
mindannyiunk számára érthető hát mondjuk
15 éve még nem igazán voltak
okos telefonok merát akkor kezdtek ugye
akkor kezdődött a az okostelefonok
korszaka jelen pillanatbany
gyakorlatilag nagyon nehéz elképzelnünk
a az életünket ezek nélkül az eszközök
nélkül tehát gyakorlatilag a
számítógépek beköltöztek általuk a
zsebünkbe és már nem csak kommunikációra
használjuk hanem nagyon-nagyon sok
minden egyébre is használjuk ezeket a
ezeket az eszközöket teljesen beépültek
a mindennapjainkba észre se vettük ezt
hogy hogy ez milyen rövid idő alatt
zajlódott le a ez a fejlődés mert benne
élve ebbe gyakorlatilag lineárisként
éljük meg ezt a változást de közben ez
nem lineáris ez egy nagyon gyors
exponenciális változás és erre a
fejlődésre gondoltam én abban a
kontextusban amikor egyébként a
rezervátum szót is emlegettem ugyanis
hogyha egy régió egy közösség nem tudja
a lépést tartani ezzel a fejlődéssel ami
még egyszer mondom meghatározza már egy
jó ideje és meg fogja határozni jó
eséllyel az elkövetkezendőkben is a a
társadalmunkat életünket akkor akkor
lemarad miért használtam ezt a
rezervátum szó hogye a rezervátumról két
dolog ugrik be legalábbis nekem
személyesen az egyik az az ez hogy egy
olyan
nem tudom terület ahol ahol valamilyen
érték veszélyeztetett érték megőrzéséről
van szó legyen szó mondjuk
legtipikusabban talán természeti
értékekre gondolunk a rezervátónál meg
van egy másik dolog ami ami es eszünkbe
jutat ugye az az a az az indián
rezervátum ami ugye a
az indián lakosságnak gyakorlatilag egy
egy kényszer lakhelye
a kultúra megőrzés álcájába
burkolva de ez csak egy csak egy csak
negatív konnotációk
ugranak be erről és akkor miért mertem
én akkor ezt a rezervátum szót használni
egyrészt az hogy itt
nekünk a mi régiónkban hogy vannak
értékeink és és megőrzésre érdemes
értékeink az az nem is kérdés legyen szó
akár természeti vonalról legyen szó akár
kulturális vonalról most a kérdés az
hogy hogy hogy ezek veszélyben vannak-e
és bizonyos
szempontokból lehet hogy azt azt
mondhatjuk hogy igen egy egy konkrét
gondolat amit szintén nagyon sokszor
hangsúlyoztam hogy ennek a szerintem
ennek a ennek a régiónak a
tulajdonképpen legnagyobb vagy egyik
legnagyobb problémája az az volt hogy
már hosszú ideje mondhatnám azt hogy
nettó kibocsátó volt a szürkeállomány
szempontjából tehát nagyon jellemző az
hogy a tehetséges fiataljaink elmennek
mondjuk más városokba
egyetemre tovább tanulni ami egyébként
nagyon helyes nagyon jó hogy ez ez
megtörténik ami nem annyira jó hogy
utána kis arány vagy kisebb arányban
térnek vissza mert úgy gondolják hogy
máshol jobb körülményeket találnak jobb
szakmai lehetőséget találnak egy jobb
jobb életkörülményeket tudnak teremteni
ilyen szempontból maguknak és hogyha nem
tudunk ezen a folyamaton valahogy fogást
találni és nem tudjuk ezeket a
folyamatokat megváltoztatni akkor az
elkerülhetetlenül azzal fog járni
hosszútávon hogy a gyakorlatilag a
közösség az az az az elöregedik elfogy
mondjuk egy kicsit akkor sarkítva vagy
egy darabig még biztos hogy lesznek majd
nem tudom turisták akik szívesen
eljönnek itt a hegyekbe kirándulni és
közben megnézni a népviseletbe öltözött
néniket bácsikat amíg még velünk lesznek
ezek a népvép de őöö nénébe vátsik de
aztán egy idő után ez is ez ez is kifogy
általt hogyha jelenünk a múltról szólna
igen nem fog tehát nem azt akarom
mondani hogy kiürül ez a ez a régió mert
nem fog pont azért mert itt itt itt or
értékek vannak de mindenképpen
megváltozik tehát ez a közösség mai
formájában
gyakorlatilag megszűnik átalakul
idejöhetnek majd már most is jellemző
ide jönnek majd
máshonnan például jellemzően nyugdíjasok
itt nyugodtabb környezetbe letelepedni
de már kevésbé lesz tehát már nem
ugyanez a közösség lesz és nem lesz egy
élő közösség és elvesznek elveszhet
időközben nagyon sok nagyon sok érték
tehát ilyen szempontból gondolom azt
hogy hogy ezzel ezzel foglalkozni kell
meg kell talál valahogy fogást kell
találnunk ezeken a folyamatokon és meg
kell valahogy fordítsuk ezeket a ezeket
a folyamatokat
talán az indiánoknál egy jobb példa
nekem számomra a japán esete aki egy
büszke hatalom volt valójában az 1800-as
évek közepéig elképzelhetetlen volt
számára hogy vannak hatalmasabb nemzetek
mint japán az ő kultúrájuk tényleg egy
egy hihetetlenül izgalmas értek értékes
kifinomult kultúra és a az 1800-as é
éveknek a közepén egy sokkoló dolog
történt kinyitották japánt erőszakkal
tehát azt mondták hogy behajóztak és
puskákkal odamentek és azt mondták hogy
hogy mostantól kezdve ki lesztek nyitva
és mostantól kezdve
fogunk kereskedni és e ez ez ezt
egyszerűen nem tudták megemészteni a
japánok vagyis hogy egész gyorsan
megemésztették idézőjelben nagy tehát ez
egy egyszerre egy egy izgalmas negatív
példa iss pozitív példa is azok akik
akik azt gondolt hogy ez nem történhet
meg velük megtörtént velük és utána
pedig valójában emberi tehát ilyen
nemzetek szempontjából nagyon-nagyon
rövid idő alatt egy o mennyi 70 év alatt
100 év alatt behozták ezt a lemaradást
iszonyatos tempóban fejlődtek és és
erről akarok egy kicsit beszélgetni hogy
nekünk itt székelyföldön akik mi itt
vagyunk egyszerre történik velünk mind a
kettő hogy hogy ha bezárkózunk és azt
mondjuk hogy ez a digitalizáció nem a
múltunkról szól nem illik bele valahogy
a székely lélekbe az hogy
most a traktoraink digitális és és gps
vezéreltek legyenek viszont a másik
oldalról az van hogy hogy szeretnénk
fejlődni és szeretnénk megújulni na egy
kicsit erről beszélgetnék veled hogy
tudom hogy egy csomó minden gondolatod
van ezzel kapcsolatban egy jó jó pár
ötleted és hogy lelkesít téged ez a téma
úgyhogy vissza is adom a szót mi mi mi a
véleményed hogy most hol tartunk ebbe
ebben a pillanatban iss hogy mi mi
kellene a következő időszakban a
fókuszunk legyen hogyan kell gondoljunk
erre a a váltásra erre a digit
digitalizációra hát az semmiképpen nem
megoldás hogyha bezárkozunk vagy vagy
elzárkozunk tehát a digitalizáció és a
technológiai fejlődés az nem fogja
kikérni a véleményünket hogy hogy ő ő
haladhat-e előre tehát ez ez ez haladni
fog előre ez a ez a folyamat úgyhogy más
választás igazából nincs ezzel meg kell
próbálni lépést tartani és igazából mit
jelent ez
az nem megoldás hogy hogy még egyszer
mondom hogyha elzárkozunk hogyha
démonizáljuk ezt a ezt a ezt a
folyamatot hogyha hogyha ha tiltjuk
úgymond mert ez nem vezet megoldásra
hanem azt az energiát amit erre
fordítanánk azt sokkal inkább arra
kellene fordítsuk hogy hogy megértsük
hogy tanuljunk hogy tudatosan tudjunk
élni vele tehát elíjük azt hogy ezt
gyakorlatilag mi tudjuk eszközként
használni ö ne kiszolgáltatottai legyünk
esözévé váljun így van
igen jó hát akkor akkor kicsit menjünk
az oktatás irányába ugyanis te egy
nagyon érdekes sokéltű személy vagy és
emiatt nagyon szép szépen körbe fogjuk
tudni járni ezt a témát egyrészt van egy
erős akadémiai háttered jelenleg is mint
egyetemi oktató
dolgozol többek között 50 publikációban
van
vagy társszerzőként vagy
szerzőként részed emellett van egy erős
biznis háttered is
és és dolgozol mint informatikus nap
mint nap és emellett mint közéleti
személy és
mint most a gyakorlatilag politikai
szerepvállalásod is lesz a következő
időszakban tehát hogy hogy ezt szeretném
egy kicsit összegyúrni mert ez nagyon
izgalmas hogy valójában kezdjük egyszer
az oktatási résszel röviden össze
tudnád-e foglalni nekem hogy hogy mi az
amivel az elmúlt jó pár évben mint
oktatás szempontjából mint oktató és
mint közéleti személy foglalkoztál és
akkor ebből ki tudunk majd
valamerre lyukadni van van konkrétan egy
pár másik kérdésem ezzel kapcsolatban
ühüm hát én alapvetően informatikus
vagyok és egyébként itt ami amiket
felsoroltál ez ez mindigaz szerencsére
minden mindennel is összefügg
innen indulnék el hogy én informatikus
informatikus vagyok hát először hogy
kerültem kapcsolat egyáltalán ezzel az
informatikával ez jó rég történt tehát
ez m még a múlt évezredben még egy másik
rendszerben nem tudom már harmadik vagy
negyedik osztályban az első találkozás
ugye a számítógéppel a akkor még
pionírház kereteiben az az az számomra
egy egy ilyen csodálatos találkozás volt
mert engem nagyon lenyűgözött az hogy
hogy hogy hogy van egy eszköz aminek én
amit be tudok programozni ami végrehajt
nekem utána valamilyen utasításokat ak
persze ezek még ilyen román gyártmányú
kis számítógépek tv-rel kapcsolató kis
számítógépek voltak amit ilyen
szekvenciális spectrum basic
programozási nyelvben lehetett
programozgatni de már önmagában az
valami fantasztikus volt hogy egyáltalán
megjelenik ott a program hatására valami
a a tévéképernyőn és nem csak a szokásos
párt propagandát lehet látni azon a azon
a képernyőn úgyhogy attól kezdveen már
így eléggé köbe volt vésve az hogy én
ezzel ezzel szeretnék foglalkozni hát ez
mondom harmadik- negyedik osztály az nem
tudom olyan
8889 magassága tehát még a kommunizmus
bukása előtt egy pcivel be hz volt még
úgyhogy ami később ugye ugye cimbora
házba alakult de akkor még pionírház
volt és azt m ettől kezdve hogy elégé
kőbe volt fésve hogy én infóval fogok
foglalkozni ez így is történt tehát
miután én tudvarjen elvégeztem a gimiben
a középiskolát akkor ezen a vonalon
mentem tovább először vásárhelyre utána
kolozsvárra egyetemre tehát matematikát
informatikát tanultam az egyetemen és
egyébként ott volt egy következő
találkozás tehát akkor már tudtam
programozgatni vagy legalábbis sejtettem
a szólt y sejtésem arról hogy miről szól
a
a programozás viszont akkor találkoztam
egy egy egy másik történettel ami ugye a
mesterséges intelligencia ami megint
hasonlóan mint a találkozás a
számítógéppel megint csak lenyűgözött
mert ugye azt láttam hogy hogy nem csak
az működik amihez akkor már
többé-kevésbé hozzá voltunk szokva hogy
akkor akkor sorról sorra leírva az
utasításokat programozzuk mi a
számítógépet hanem fel tudunk építeni
olyan rendszereket amelyek már képesek
tanulásra képesek ezáltal az
általánosításra úgyhogy akkor ez lett
egy egy vonal amivel
hangsúlyosabban elkezdtem foglalkozni és
aztán ez vezetett oda hogy amit ugye
mondtál az akadémiai pálya először ugye
mesteri utána doktori 2007-ben védtem
meg a bábzsboain a doktorátusomat
ilyesmi témakörben tehát mesterséges
intelligencia természetből inspirált
számítástechnikai modellek és hát a
doktori védésemet követően maradtam a az
egyetemen oktatóként és akkor innen
indul az a az az oktatói
kutatói oktatói pálya amire amire
rákérdeztél egyébként a kutatási vonalon
aztán következett egy váltás tehát
ezekkrő a ezekről a témakörökről ugye
egy picit át került a fókusz a az
összetettebb osztott szoftver
rendszerekre software engineering
témakörökre úgyhogy jelen pillanatban
nem is vagyok aktív
tudom beszéltük azt hogy majd
mesterséges intelligenciáról is fogunk
beszélni amit amit szívesen várok
viszont azt megjegyzem hogy jelen
pillanatban már nem vagyok aktív
ö vagy nagyon aktív kutató ezen a
területen vannak olyan projektjeink
értelemszerűen ahol használjuk ezeket a
legújabb modelleket is de kutatóként már
más más a a fókuszom és visszatérve
akkor innen indult a az oktatói karrier
is és az oktatásban énát az egyetemi
oktatásban én mindig egy olyan vonalat
képviseltem ami megpróbálja erősíteni a
gyakorlati
tárgyak szerepét illetve a privát
szektorral a cégekkel történő
együttműködést lehetőleg úgy hogy ez nem
nem ne úgy ne úgy érts hogy ez az
elméleti oktatás kárára menjen hanem
mondjuk úgy hogy egy egészségesebb
egyensúly tudjon kialakulni a
a kettő között és kolozsvári
tartózkodásom ideje alatt többnyire
ilyen
projekteket próbáltunk meg kezdeményezni
vagy
végigvinni
[Zene]
eléggé sikeresen tehát hogy sok sok
mindenről ne beszé sok minden tartozik
ehhez tehát kezdve attól hogy mondjuk
úgy megreformáltuk a a vagy próbáltuk
megreformálni az infós államvizsga
kiértékelés folyamatát a diákköri
konferenciákon nagyobb hangsúlyt
kapjanak ezek a gyakorlati részek magába
az egyetemi tananyagba is értelemszerűen
ezek hangsúlyosabban jelenjenek meg a
céges együttműködéseket próbáltuk ilyen
szervezettebb formában összerakni
először a egyetemi oldalról utána az én
esetemben volt egy pici szemléletváltás
ugye a a más oldalról tehát a cégek
illetve céges
tömörülések oldaláról próbáljam ezeket
ezeket megszervezni azzal a
megjegyzéssel hogy ez is mindig jellemző
volt hogy mindig
részt vettem vagy mindig az az a kutatói
vagy egyetemi oktatói vonal mellett
mindig ott volt számomra ez a a privát
szektorban történő tevékenykedés tehát
mindig valamilyen formában vettem részt
szoftver projektek fejlesztésében is
kezdetekben kis magánvállalkozások
kereteiben most már
több mint 10 éve ugy a kotspring
csapatában tehát mindig megvolt ez a ami
egyébként összefügg tehát hogy a a az
oktatásban is
tudom alkalmazni a ezt a
fejlesztési tapasztalatot illetve
fordítva a
privátszektorból tudunk így akkor
könnyebben létrehozni facilitálni
oktatási programokat vagy hozzájárulni a
a igen a az a privátszektor az egy az
egy nagyon fontos információforrás hogy
mi az ami releváns manapság tehát az a
realitás mert ami nem működik a privát
szektorban az azt jelenti hogy azért nem
hajlandóak az emberek fizetni az azt
jelenti hogy nem releváns ezér mert mert
úgy önmagában az oktatás az sok irányba
elmehet ami nem releváns úgyhogy ez egy
érdekes kettőssége így és egy nagyon
hasznos praktikus kettőssége így az
életednek hogy hogy mind a kettő benne
van
igen talán a a vagy közéleti vonalrólra
nem reflektáltam még ugye azt is
említetted az is jelen volt mindig tehát
kezdve attól hogy annak idején
diákszervezeti
tevékenységeket követően hoztuk létre
például az ergo egyesületet ami azóta is
is működik majd a a említettem már
ezeket az informatikai cégtömörüléseket
ugye például az it plus klaszternek
nagyon rég aktív tagja vagyok meg néhány
éve
elnöke tehát hogy ez mindig jelen volt
ez a
ez a ez a civil vonal is és megint csak
összefügg az előzőekkel ugye mert
például egy ilyen klaszternek a
tevékenysége is azon kívül hogy hogy
szakmai közösséget próbálunk építeni a
tevékenységeinek nagyon-nagyon fontos
alappillérét képezik például az oktatási
programok vagy vagy akár a szakmai
rendezvények aminek megint van egy
kapcsolata ugye nyilvánvalóan az
akadémiai szférával is úgyhogy ezek így
így ilyen szempontból összefüggdnek
egy kicsit még kérdeznélek a magáról az
it clasterről
aminek az alapítója vagy tudtommal vagy
vagy pedig ha nem is az alapítója
mindenképpen a mozgatórugója részt
veszek az alapításra utt a klaszter
tevékenységben ugye a klasztert azt
alapvetően a tagjai cégek meg az
alapítók is cégek nem magánszemélyek de
igen jelen vagyok a klaszter
tevékenységébenben már gyakorlatilag a
megalapítását vagy már a kezdeteket
követően gyere gyere mutasd be nekünk
hogy mi ez az it klaszter és kik kik
tartoznak és kik tartozhatnak ide meg mi
a jelentősége ennek a klaszter üüm hát
ugye a klaszter klaszter fogalom úgy
hogy általában beszélünk ebben a ebben a
kontextusban erről akkor akkor
gyakorlatilag három fontos alappillér
szükséges egy klaszterhez tehát szükség
van cégekre szükség van oktatási
intézményekre és szükség van
önkormányzati együttműködésre és
nyilvánvalóan a klaszterk azok úgy
szerveződnek hogy valamilyen konkrét
szakmai doméniumban illetve tipikusan
valamilyen regionálisan is valamilyen
egy adott területen tevékenykedő
intézmények állnak össze egy ilyen
tömörülésbe miért teszik ezt azért
mert vannak olyan vagy projektek
programok amelyeket közösen
hatékonyabban
tudnak megvalósítani mint külön-külön
hát erről szól gyakorlatilag ez az it
klaszter is itt most konkrétan az it
plus klasztert a székelyföldi it
klaszterként is szokták emlegetni mert
többnyire székelyföldi it cégeket fog
egybe és a projektjeiben szorosan
együttműködik oktatási intézmények
elsősorban felsőoktatási intézményekkel
illetve az önkormányz okkal vannak
egyébként székelyföldön kívüli tagjaai
is a klaszternek de jellemzően
székelyföld és jellemzőbben
szoftvercégek nem csak tehát vannak
telekomcégek vannak hardver cégek sőt
vannak termelésben vagy
termékforgalmazásban tevékenykedő cégek
is akik mondjuk már elég nagyok ahhoz
hogy legyen egy ilyen különálló akár it
depart mjuk akár ilyen it fejlesztési
vonaluk alapvetően tehát informatikai
cégeket fog egybe és ezek a cégek olyan
programokat szerveznek közösen amelyek a
helyi szektor fejlődését facilitálják
sokféle ilyen projektprogram van kezdve
attól a konkrét fejlesztésekben történő
együttműködésekben amikor mondjuk több
cég valósít meg egy projektet
amik kintről is vagy a publikusan is
úgymond jobban jobban látható talán azok
a a rendezvények illetve az oktatási
programok ugye elég sok
rendezvényt szervezünk ezek
nagyon-nagyon fontosak olyan szempontból
hogy láthatóbbá tudjuk tenni a
a a helyi szektort és hát ide tartozik
ugye a klasznek a nagy konferenciája
digitális székhelyföld konferencia a az
udvarhelyi rendezvények a digitális
kaláka vagy a hargita
informatikus találkozó másik nagyon
fontos pillér a az oktatási programok
itt is több minden van tehát van
mentorprogramunk egyetemisták számára
van mentorprogramunk középiskolások
számára illetve van átképzési programunk
vagy más területekről képezünk át
szoftverfejlesztésbe ö szakembereket
most egy e már egy ideje egy mesteri
programnak az elindításán is dolgozunk
ugye az egyetemmel közösen tehát
nagyjából hasonló tevékenységeket
takar ez a ez a történet ez ez nagyon
izgalmas egy kicsit még az oktatási
részéről beszélgetnék mert tényleg ez
érinti a legtöbb embert mert
beszélgettünk erről a korszakváltásról
és most ha valaki nem informatikai
pályát választott magának és már
elindult egy valamilyen úton te fel
elvégzett egy menedzment szakot és
időközben rájön arra hogy egyrészt
minden szakmában manapság informatikai
alaptudás fog kelleni tehát hogy kell
tudjunk használni pár eszközt amit nap
mint nap fogunk majd
egyre egyre egyre több eszköz kell
megtanuljunk és egyre gyorsabban és
hatékonyabban kell tudjuk használni
másik oldalról pedig lehet hogy néhány
emberben megfogalmazódik hogy lehet hogy
jó lenne hogyha ha beleásnám magát
jobban az informatikába esetleg mint
informatikus képzelni el a munkáját
tegyük fel meg akar tanulni programozni
vagy teszter akar lenni és ez az a pont
ahol ahol talán érdemes lenne egy kicsit
beszélgessünk erről az átképzésről erről
a programról amit évről évre
meghirdettek
úgyhogy át is adom a szót mutasd be ezt
a programot egy picit jobban ühüm ki
jelentkezhet mennyi idő milyen mélységű
ez az oktatás és mi lesz a végeredménye
ennek ez a bábesbi tudományegyetemmel
közösen szervezett tehát igaz az egyetem
által működtetett program ez egy
akkreditált posztgraduális képzés az
első és asszassiszem még mindig az
egyetlen a az országban egyébként ami
magyar nyelvű ilyen ilyen képzést nyújt
hát ez egy jó másfél év a lefutása ennek
a programnak és hát posztgraduális
képzésként olyanok vehetnek részt benne
akik már valamilyen más szakon egyetemi
végzettséggel rendelkeznek diplomával
rendelkeznek jellemzően így ahogy mondod
olyanok a a a résztvevők az érdeklődők
akik vagy át szeretnének igazolni egy
másik szakmából az it a
szoftverfejlesztés világába vagy már
szoftverfejlesztésben tevékenykednek de
nem ez irányú a az egyetemi végzettségük
és mondjuk úy a tudásukat szeretnék
rendszerezni kiegészíteni a képzés által
vagy a harmadik kategória azok akik
például valamilyen nem tudom
interdiszciplináris szempontból a saját
területükön akarják alkalmazni ezeket az
it ö módszereket
ezt ott akarják felhasználni ezt az
informatikai tudást
nagyon sok egyébként ilyen egy adott
ponton nagyon-nagyon sok ilyen ilyen
képzési programot
indított el a privát szektor is
sok volt ezek között vagy elég sok volt
ami amit én úgy gondolom hogy
hogy hogy nem lehetett működőképes tehát
azért ez egy elég összetett
és nem egy könnyű szakma tehát itt nem
nem tud az megtörténni hogy akkor most
hirtelen valamilyen csoda folytán akkor
két hét alatt valakit kiképezzünk
programozónak ez így nem működik a mi
programunk pont ezért egy amikor
összeraktuk ennek a szerkezetét
koncepcióját az volt az elképzelés hogy
egy
olyan stabil átfogó alapot tudjon
nyújtani azok számára akik ezt elvégzik
ami megalapozza a tudásukat és utána
erre a tudásra alapozva el tudnak
indulni bármilyen to toábbi szakosodási
vonal tehát azonnal el tudnak
helyezkedni mondjuk egy kezdő junior
szintű fejlesztőként egy valamilyen
cégnél és utána rá tudnak tehát
meglesznek az alapjaai alapjaik arra
hogy rá tudjak építeni
arra akár technológiaspecifikus tudást
ezekre az alapokra akár el tudnak
indulni valamilyen szakosodás irányában
akár szervezett képzési képzések
kereteiben mondjuk mesteri programok
kereteiben akár akár egyénileg tehát
hogyha úgy is képzelhetnénk el hogy
nagyjából ezt nek a úgy néz ki ennek a
posztgraduális programnak a a a tanterve
vagy szerkezete hogy a az alapképzés
tananyagából vegyük ki a a az mondjuk az
ilyen elméleti elméleti tárgyakat vagy
azokat a tárgyakat amik már valamilyen
szakosodás irányába mutatnak ezenkívül
még elvégeztünk néhány összevonást hogy
mégis csak egy jó másfél év alatt azért
ezt lehessen elvégezni és amit kaptunk
az azt az azt mi úgy gondoljuk hogy
ebből most már egy gyufas állat se
lehetne elvenni anélkül hogy
hogy megmaradjon tehát hogy érvényes
maradjon ez az elv hogy meglegyenek azok
a stabil alapok amire utána rá tud
építeni a
a végzős diákunk nem egy könnyű program
úgy van kitalálva hogy kompatibilis
legyen a azzal hogyha már valakinek van
egy családja van egy másik munkahelye
tehát jellemzően hétvégi képzések
formájában valósul meg ez ilyen
szekvenciálisan egymást követő
modulok kereteiben történik az oktatás
van egy elég hangsúlyos gyakorlati része
szakmai gyakorlattal egybekötve egy
szintén a klaszter illetve a cégek
együttműködésében valósul meg viszont
tehát nem egy nem egy könnyű
sztori nem egy nem egy nem egy sétagalob
de
de az eddigi évfolyamok alapján azt
tudom mondani hogy hogy hogy nagyon jól
működik én személyesen oktatóként is
résztveszek a programban és
nagyon-nagyon szeretem tehát akik akik
ezt
ezt bevállal ák hogy hogy hogy részt
vesznek azok részéről már egy olyan
elköteleződést és egy olyan szintű
tudatosságot igényel ez ami ami nem
biztos hogy egyébként megvan mondjuk még
egy egy egy fiatalabb akár alapképzéses
diák diák esetében ugye pont ezért ezek
a képzések ezek rendkívül jó hangulatúak
nagyon nagyon interaktívak nagyon vagány
csapatok vesznek részt úgyhogy úgyhogy
ilyen szempontból csak jókat tudok
mondani a hát igen az aki ekkora
áldozatot hoz az életébe hogy részt
vegyen egy ilyen másfél éves képzésben
az biztos hogy komolyan gondolja és és
mekkora a sikerráta íg van tehát am
miután elvégzik ezeket a a képzéseket
egyrészt kapnak-e munkát másrészt pedig
hogy hogy tényleg elhelyez szakmát
váltanak-e ezek az emberek most egyik
oldalról mondtam hogy nem könnyű a
képzés tehát van egy lemorzsolódás de az
jellemzően már időközben időközben
megtörténik sőt jellemzően a képzésnek
az első első felében tehát annak
ellenére hogy van egy felvétel is ami
nem kér inf informatikai előzetes tudást
viszont bizonyos például logikus
gondolkodás vagy ilyen nem tudom
informatikai általános műveltség vagy
hasonló dolgokat próbálunk mérni ezáltal
de a felvételi ellenére van egy
lemorzsolódás tehát egy-egy évflyamot
úgy úgy kell konkrétan elképzelni hogy
25-ös csoportokb szoktuk ezt indítani és
mondjuk olyan 15 körül szokott lenni
azoknak a száma akik a végén sikeresen
le is diplomáznak a másik rész amire
rákérdezté hogy mennyire sikeresen
tudnak elhelyezkedni az eddigi végzős
évfolyamok esetében én azt gondolom hogy
nagyonnagyon jók ilyen szempontból a az
eredmények tehát én azt gondolom hogy
mindenki minden részvevő aki elvégezte a
képzést megtalálta a számítását a
sajátját ami volt az adott képzéssel
kapcsolatban ami lehet hogy az volt hogy
akkor ő szakmát váltson és akkor mondjuk
egy másik szakmából átigazoljon egy
szoftvercégné helyezkedjen el akár
fejlesztőként akár ahogy így
mondtad tesztelőként
a ha az volt a célja hogy a saját
szakmájában alkalmazza ezt a tudást
akkor akkor erre is nagyon szép példák
vannak hogy ez ez is vagy nagyon jó
sikersztorik vannak hogy ez is sikerült
azoknak akik akiknek ez volt a célja én
remélem hogy a most végzős évfolyam akik
most szeptemberben a hónap végén fognak
védeni ők is
hasonló sikerességgel tudnak majd
elhelyezkedni azzal a megjegyzéssel hogy
hogy ők egy picivel nehezebb helyzetben
vannak azért ilyen szempontból mint
mondjuk a a az előző évfolyamok egész
egyszerűen a a a piac meg a szektor
jelenlegi
helyzete miatt de én remélem hogy hogy
sikeresen veszik majd ők is ezt a ühüm
igen egy kicsit beszélgetnék arról a a
tehát hogy volt egy hullám ami az
informatika szektoron keresztül ment ez
a covid idő alatt a a covid az egy
hatalmas bezárkózódással járt mindenki
számára és ezzel együtt nagyon
intenzíven azt láttam hogy az
informatikai piac viszont elindult mivel
mindenki online kezdett el dolgozni és
és ennek több dimenziója volt tehát
egyrészt a kommunikációs cégek nagyon
megduzzadtak felnőttek erősebbé váltak
és és és az online tevékenység erősebbé
vált viszont egy izoláció is
ezzel elindult a home officeenak a a
széleskörű elterjedése amúgy még most is
érezzük ezt hogy otthonról nagyon
szeretnek dolgozni az emberek és
igazából annyira nem is bánják a
munkaadók hogy homeofice-ba dolgoznak a
a ez egy nagyon furcsa világot
eredményezett ami részben ott is
megnyilvánul hogy most már annyira nem
fontos hogy melyik országba vagy melyik
városban dolgozunk kinyílt a világ
számunkra és egy székely programozó pont
úgy dolgozhat együtt egy olyan csapatban
ahol a csapat
egyhada nem tudom német egy egyhada
székely egyharmada mexikói és és nap
mint nap ez időzónákon keresztül ezt
pontosan
összevegy ő és és
egy kicsit a a véleményre lennék
kíváncsi hogy ez a
bezárkózódás ezt te egyrészt hogy hogy
élted meg kezdjük a személyes oldalról
te hogyan élted meg ezt a
covid-időszakot és hogy utána akkor
rákérdeznék arra is hogy mit láttál a
környezetedben ennek milyen hatásai
voltak
üüm hát lehet hogy megfordítanám és
akkor egy picit a az általánosabból
jönnék vissza tehát hogy a a a tényleg a
covid időszakkal az a helyzet hogy hogy
nem teljesen általánosítható de az it
szektoron belül ennek voltak rövidtávú
pozitív hatásai is voltak cégek akiknek
akik olyan szektorokban dolgozott
akiknek nyilvánvalóan visszaesett a
a visszaestek a mutatói viszont nagyon
sok cégnek viszont nagyon-nagyon
megnövekedtek mert nagyobb lett az igény
és
digitális megoldásokra és ezek és és
ések azonnal kellettek és sok kellette
belőlük tehát hogy ilyen szempontból
volt egy
egy egy egy nagyobb megjelent egy
nagyobb kereslet egy nagyobb igény
kiderült eközben hogy a home office az
nagyon jól működik legalább is rövidtvon
tehát hogy a hatékonyság szempontjából
az hogy hogy nincsenek fizikailag egy
helyen a a fejlesztők ez a hatékonyságon
sokat nem rond tehát hogy az az it cégek
ilyen szempontból nagyon sok it cég
felpörgött ebben a az időszakban
viszont vannak közép távon ennek kevésbé
pozitív hozadékai ugye ez a office
történet a hatékonyság szempontjából
rövidtvon lehet hogy nagyon jól működik
vagy nagyon jól működik viszont azért
ennek vannak negatív hatásai
tehát rontja hosszabb távon vagy
középtávon már a csapatkohéziót ha
nagyon sokat jelentenek azok amik így
kimaradnak azok a a szünetek
gyakorlatilag a
aís a körös kávézások és hasonló és
enneknek a kimaradása ez ez ez visszahad
tehát ront a csapatkohézión ez vissza
ahat majd előbb-utóbb a csapatmunkára a
hatékonyságra a lojalitásra sok sok
minden egyébre pont ezért mert ezt
nagyon sok cég felismerte pont ezért
most már talán inkább jellemzőbb az hogy
a hibrid megoldásokat próbálják meg
támogatni tehát megmarad ez a home
office mert ugye egyfajta juttatás is
volt ez annak idején az embereknek hogy
akkor dolgozhattok otthonról is hát
valamilyen arányban ez ez megmaradt hogy
továbbra is dolgozhattok otthonról de
hát azért be kell járni valamilyen
rendszerességgel a céggel is pont azért
hogy meglegyenek ezek a
ezek a személyek tehát ezek az
interakciók és megmaradjanak ezek a a
személyes kapcsolatok egy másik
negatívabb hozadéka a történetnek az
hogy ez egy lufi is eredményezett tehát
nagyonagyon sokan azt gondolták hogy
hogy ugye megnőtt ez a ez a kereslet és
hogy ez így marad és akkor gyakorlatilag
nagyon gyorsan nagyon hirtelenneg
növekedtek sokszor talán túl nagy
kompromisszumokat hozva a humán
erőforrás
szempontjából
viszont utána nem ez történt tehát utána
nem maradt meg ugyanazon a szinten a a
kereslet és és akkor következtek ugye a
a bigtech cégeknek a nagy elbocsátásai
igen a a leépítések és ez egyébként pont
ez valamilyen szinten egyfajta nem nem
csak tehát az it szektornak a pici
megtorpanásához ugye ami az előző
időszakban jellemző volt nem ez az
egyetlen tényező ami ami miatt ez ez ez
történt de hogy mindenképpen hozzájárult
és ez még akkor is hogyha ez hosszabb
távon valószínű hogy e stabilizál
állódás tehát hogy ez én nem gondolom
azt hogy hogy ennek nagyon nem tudom
katasztrofális következményei lesznek
vagy nem tud helyre állni a a szektor de
lehet hogy nem ugyanarra a szintre jön
vissza mint ami azelőtt volt ameddig még
még még még felfújt állapotában volt ez
a a a lufi viszont ez egyfajta
stabilizálódást jelent viszont ez ez
azért fájni fog tehát lesz egy átmeneti
időszak ami és elsősorban sajnos a
kezdőket tehát a juniorokat fogja
leginkább
érinteni akik most kerülnének ki a
munkaerőpiacra vagy most végeztek el
például egy ilyen átképzést és egy jóval
nagyobb konkurenciával
néznek szembe mint mondjuk
két évvel ezelőtti elődeik kollégáik
igen ez ez ez pontosan így így érzem én
is így az elmúlt
egy bocs egy dologra nem hogy a
személyesen én hogy értem meg amúgy én
személyesen már valamennyi volt az
megelőzően is home office-ban nekem az
az volt nagyon rossz egyébként a
covid-időszakban hogy hogy minden
homeoficeba kerülte tehát odak került a
fejlesztés oda kerültek a gyűlések oda
kerültek a az órák tehát az oktatási
tevékenységek is ez így már együtt túl
sok volt igen igen
egyetértek nekem is éreztem hogy az a
bezártság az a az hogy mi a a lakásom
egyben a munkahelyem is és hogy hogy
valójában összekeveredik minden minden
nagyon nehéz volt pláne
kisgyermekekkel ez egy nagyon nehéz
időszak volt nem önmagában a home office
része mert az azelőtt is volt nálam most
is van részben de de hogy mi minden h
hogy hy minden ott történik ez ez egy
kicsit nehezebb volt minden igen ezt
azért dobtam fel ezt a a covid témát
mert az elmúlt 10 évben
körülbelül lehet hogy tizen pár év érzek
egy tendenciát ami gyakorlatilag a
covidban csúcsosodott számomra vagy a
covid utáni időszakban most csúcsosodik
számomra mégpedig az hogy tizenpár évvel
ezelőtt amikor én kolozsváron voltam és
dolgoztam az egyik multinál akkor
számomra elképzelhetetlen volt hogy haza
tudok jönni ide székelyudvarhelyre és
továbbra is egyrészt lesz munkahelyem
másrészt pedig hogy egyáltalán izgalmas
dolog hazajönni tehát amí emlékszem
ültem a buszon kolozsváron is gyászoltam
magamban a döntést hogy haza fogunk
költözni a feleségemel eldöntöttük hogy
a az öt éves házassági évfordulónkra már
itthon leszünk de azért magamban úgy így
gyászoltam hogy vajon mi fog lenni
féltem is attól hogy mi fog történni és
érdekes módon átalakult a piac és
gyakorlatilag ezzel a coviddal
csúcsosododott hogy gyakorlatilag már
teljesen mindegy hogy hol vagyok és ha
nem teljesen de ahhoz képest hogy mi
volt kolozsváron az az az a ég és föld a
kettő között a különbség és nem csak
hogy nem csak hogy egy nem egy lemondás
volt eljönni kolozsvárról hanem azt
látom hogy egy bizonyos szempontból egy
hietetlen nagy áldás volt a kisvárosnak
a jelenléte tehát logisztikai
szempontból napi egy órát minimum
megspórlok azzal hogy nem kolozsváron
megyek munka munkába hanem itt de lehet
hogy többet
és ilyen szempontból izgalmas mert a
kisvárosoknak a jelentősége megnőtt így
az elmúlt 10 évben láthatatlanul vagy
olyan nagyon lassú folyamatként éreztük
így lineáris folyamatként de valójában
ez is egy gyors folyamat volt és a
coviddal pedig abszolút ez történt hogy
mindenki amúgyis haza volt kényszerítve
és utána már nem nagyon akarodzott
visszamenni a az irodákba úgyhogy
úgyhogy azt látom hogy ha manap ide
jugadunk vissza az átképzéshez hogyha
most egy valaki úgy dönt hogy mégis
megpróbálná magát átképezni
informatikussá egy kisvárosban sokkal
több lehetősége van ma mint szerintem
mint öt évvel ezelőtt vagy akár 10 évvel
ezelőtt amikor a nagyvárosokba
koncentrálódtak azok a nagy it cégek
ahova érdemes volt menni ahol a fizetés
is sokkal nagyobb volt és most úgy érzem
hogy a kicsi székely udvarhelyen de úgy
a régiónkban sepsizentgyörgyön meg meg
gyergyóban meg meg a kisvárosokban úgy
általában mintogyha lenne egy ilyen
fellendülés ilyen szempontból érdemes
hazaköltözni érdemes lehetőségünk van
hazaköltözni és már nem nem nincs egy
ilyen szorítása a nagyvárosnak vagy akár
a külföldi nagyvárosoknak most nyilván
hogyha valaki az amazonnál szeretne
dolgozni azt most itt székely
udvarhelyen nem teheti meg ilyen
formában például ott a policy nem engedi
hogy hogy hogy valaki home office-ban
dolgozzon erősen vagyok meggyőződve de
hallottam ilyen hangokat kíváncsi vagyok
hogy te ezt hogy látod ezt a ezt a
tendenciát hogy hogy a kisvárosoknak a a
lehetőségei sokkalsokkal jobbak lettek
mint ezelőtt 10 évvel hát maga maga a
szakmánk olyan ami nem annyira helyhez
kötött
ilyen szempontból kevésbé függ például a
nem tudom nagyobb infrastrukturális
fejlesztésektől most van-e repülőtér
van-e autópálya nem azt mondom hogy
teljesen független de sokkal kevésbé
függettől mint sok más sok más szektor
kevésbé helyhez kötött teljesen igaz az
amit el mondtál hogy főleg mondjuk már
családosként egy kisváros sok
szempontból sokkal élhetőbb tud lenni
egy
nagyvárossal összehasonlítva most
mindemellett azért az volt jellemző és
továbbra is az jellemző hogy a nagyobb
it központok azok a nagyvárosokba tehát
az egyetemi központok köré tömörülnek ez
nem fog rövid távon
változni értelemszerűen
de igen esélye van a kisebb városoknak
is arra hogy hogy rácsatlakozzanak tehát
gyakorlatilag labdába rúgjanak ezen a
ebben a történetben akár rácsatlakozza
ezekre a a a központokra így van
kialakítsanak helyileg is egy olyan
pezsgő szakma életet a szektoron belül
ami ami ami aztán alapot ad a további
fejlődésre igen nőttek a vagy nőhetnek
az esélyek mondjuk maguktól nem fognak
azért tenni is kell pontosan ha tetszik
ez az epizód akkor kérlek iratkozz fel a
csatornánkra vagy írd meg kommentbe hogy
milyen más témár ról hallanámég szívesen
és akkor még ehhez még hozzácsatolnám
tehát ezek mind olyan tendenciák amit az
elmúlt négy évben értettem meg a a
azáltal hogy folyamatosan beszélgettünk
és a eleinte nekem is absztrakt volt
hogy mit csinál az it claster hogy miért
is érdemes hozzá csatlakozni hogy m mik
melyek is a tevékenységei mi mi is a
célja és azért absztrakt mert valójában
egy hihetetlenül komplex világot élünk
ahol egy digitális stratégia akár egy
város számára vagy egy egy régió számára
amiről te már beszéltél akkor amikor én
még csak úgy füleltem hogy miről mi mi
mi mi is ez mit jelent az hogy digitális
stratégia e szóval ez egy hihetetlenül
komplex és rengeteg oldala van van
oktatási oldala van politikai oldala
gazdasági oldala van kutatási oldala
szóval annyi minden oldala van hogy hogy
tényleg erről lehetne beszélgetni és
lehet hogy még fogunk is a jövőben most
egy picit az az oktatási oldalát jártuk
körbe viszont számomra ami lelkesítő
volt ebben az it claszterben és a
tevékenységében az az hogy lehetőséget
ad egy sokkal szélesebb réteg nek mint
akinek eddig lehetősége volt arra hogy
átképződjön hogy beintegrálódjon egy
rendszerbe munkahelyet kapjon amibe
amivel valószínűleg a fizetése is jóval
nőni fog és emellett mindenféle
programokat szerveztek konferenciákat
szerveztek amin én is többek között
részt vettem nagyon izgalmas volt ez ezt
látni hogy hogyan hoztak össze tehát egy
közösség formáló ereje is van ennek a az
it klasternek tehát tényleg valójában
ilyen szempontból a jövőbe kell lássatok
és hogy hogy olyan dolgokon dolgozzatok
ami nem annyira nyilvánvaló most ebben a
pillanatban hogy gyümölcsöt fog hozni de
lehet hogy a következő öt évben vagy 10
évbe fog gyümölcsöt hozni úgyhogy
úgyhogy kedves hallgató figyelmébe
ajánlom az it classernek a
tevékenységeit mert nem magától értetődő
hogy van egy ilyen sokkal egyszerűbb sőt
azt kell hogy mondjam sokkal egyszerűbb
lenne hogy ne létezzen az it claster
mint az hogy létezik tehát nem nem egy
olyan valami ami úgy magától létrejön
mert létre szoktak jönni it klaszterk
hanem kőkemény munka van nagyon sok
embernek a munkája van benne hogy hogy
létezzen és tudom hogy nagyon viharos is
volt az elmúlt pár év olyan szempontból
hogy hogy több támogatásra lett volna
szükség és és sokszor azon a határon
voltál hogy vajon meg éri-e ezt csinálni
vagy nem éri megcsinálni ezt az it
klasztert úgyhogy nem tudom ehhez
akarnál egy kommentet fűzni hogy a a a
viharos időszakhoz ha nem akkor pedig
felteszem a következő kérdésemet mehet a
következő kérdés jó akkor nem
kommentáljuk ezt az időszakot szóval
az it claster egy olyan szervezet
amelyik a gondolkozik a jövőn és
megpróbálja azt megelőzni tehát hogy
hogy olyan lépéseket tenni amelyek nem
amelyek hatására nem váratlanul fog érni
az a változás és hogyha most megnézzük
ugyancsak a csak az információs
korszakbeli változásokat én látok
nagyobb trendeket amik átformálták a
világunkat tehát az első nagy trend az a
pc tehát a személyi számítógépnek a a a
széleskörű elterjedése hogy az a
képesség hogy hogy lefuttassunk egy
programkódot már nem egy szűk elitnek a
a a kiváltsága hanem gyakorlatilag pont
amikor te mondtad hogy a kommunizmus
bokása előtti időszakban már te a
számítógépeden otthon a tévére rákap
csatlakozva már futtattál programkódot
és ez ez egy hihetetlenül átalakította a
világunkat és akkor jött a következő az
az internetnek a a a a az
összekötöttségnek a a világa amelyik
hihetetlenül ugyancsak átalakította a
világunkat és és akkor erre jött 2 körül
amikor a a az okos telefonok elindultak
és az is annyira átalakította a
világunkat egyre egymásra tevődnek de
egyre nagyobbak ezek a hullámok tehát ki
az akinek manapság nincs okos telefonja
és és
gyakorlatilag úgy használjuk mint a a
testünknek a kiegészítője mint a
memóriánk kiegészítője mint a a a a a
egy egy nélkülözhetetlen eszköz ahhoz
hogy jól tudjunk funkcionálni ebbe a
világba és a ez a három hullám annak
ellenére hogy egyre nagyobb hatást
gyakorolt az életünkre úgy érzem hogy az
ai hullám ez egy nagyobb hullám lesz
mint ami az előzők között volt át fogja
alakítani ez az én megérzésem a
világunkat de nem tudom pontosan
megfogni hogy hogyan hogy milyen irányba
fogja alakítani és hogy egyáltalán
honnan is jött ez a a mintogyha semmiből
tűnt volna fel úgyha az első kérdésem
ezzel az ai hullámmal kapcsolatban egy
pár kérdés erejéig erről szeretnék
kicsit beszélgetni veled hogy miért most
tűnt fel ez az ai hullám tehát a
neurális hálók ami aminek a a tehát a
nagy nyelvi modellek ami által
működhetnek ezek a neurális hálók ezek a
60-as években is voltak már akkor
kezdtünk el dolgozni rajta akkor persze
volt egy ilyen hurrá optimizmus a 60-as
években hogy hogy az általános
mesterséges intelligencia az hamarosan
most már csak pár évtizednyire vagyunk
és és itt lesz még most sincs itt
viszont viszont utána annak ellenére
hogy volt egy hurá optimizmus utána
minthogyha egy kicsit úgy úgy úgy
elcsitult volna ez a ez a ez a a hullám
és akkor most hirtelen hirtelen
idézőjelbe bár mondhatnám hirtelen is
mert 2022 őszén vagy novemberében amikor
a chat gpt megjelent egy hatalmasat
robbant úgyhogy te minek tudod be azt
hogy hogy a mesterséges intelligencia az
elmúlt hát 60 évben nem igen 60 évben
gyakorlatilag minthogyha egy ilyen
csendesebb időszaka után hirtelen
minthogyha megint elő tört volna ühüm
hát én személyesen a a robbanást vagy
ezt a legújabb robbanást amiről beszél
én személyesen nem 2022-re tenném hanem
2015-26
tájára ugye 2016-ban volt az amikor a ha
nem tévedek amikor az alfa go a
google-nek a mesterséges intelligenciá
bajnok megverte a go bajnokot és mitől
olyan érdekes ez tehát hogy mert hát 9
7-ben talán az ibm-nek a debue rendszere
megverte akkor a a sakvilágbajnokot
kasparovot akkor akkor mitől érdekesebb
ez a ez a
15-16-os momentum mindjárt elmondom de
előbb akkor egy picit visszalépnék tehát
hogy tényleg ez a ez a a mesterséges
intelligencia most a a főleg 2022-től
errefele nagyon-nagyon berobbant úgymond
a köztudatba és a közbeszédbe de azért
ez nem egy új dolog tehát gyakorlatilag
a mesterséges intelligenciának mint
tudomány területnek a történetét nézzük
az tulajdonképpen egy idős az
informatikával tehát gyakorlatilag
mindig is volt mert nagyjából hasonlóról
is tát minden végül is minden
technológiai fejlődés fejlesztést mire
vezethetünk vissza valamilyen szinten
ugye kényelmesebbé vagy hatékonyabbá
akartuk tenni a a az életünket amikor
kényelmetlen vagy kevéssé volt hatékony
az hogy hogy hogy a kezünkkel túrjuk a
földet akkor kitaláltunk különböző
szerszámokat ami kiegészítetik vagy akár
helyettesíthetik a kezeinket most egy
kicsit a számításchn számítógéppel is ez
a helyzet csak ott ugye nem a kezünk
hanem a az agyunk a
kiegészítendő néha
helyettesítendő eszköz tehát ugye erre
erre keressük a megoldást vagy akár
konkrétan ennek a működését
akarjuk valahogy valahogy modellezni
egyébként miér akarjuk modellezni hát
azért mert az agyunk az egy az egy az
egy csodálatos eszköz
nagyon-nagyon komplex problémák
megoldására képes am már bizonyítja az
is hogy most mi itt beszélgetünk cserébe
nagyon-nagyon bonyolult is nagyon nagyon
a komplexitása tehát pont ezért az azért
nehezebb tanulmányozni megérteni
modellezni elég régóta foglalkozunk
ezzel vagy vannak tudomány külön
tudomány területek amik ezzel ezzel
foglalkoznak úgyhogy nagyon sokat
haladtunk is ezen a téren de még mindig
nem
teljesen megoldás ugye komplexitás tehát
nagyjából ugye 100 milliárd neuron
mindegyik átlagosan 10000 másikkal
kapcsolatban hogy az idegrendszerünkön
belül tehát ez egy olyan szintű
komplexitás ami már eléggé
nehézzé teszi a megértését és és
tanulmányozását most a számítógépek
ehhez képest végül is relatíve mondjuk
úgy egyszerűek tehát hogyha
belegondolunk akkor a klasszikus
processzoraink azok néhány egyszerű
alapművelet elvégzésére képesek viszont
ezt annyira gyorsan csinálják hogy hogy
ez lehetővé teszi hogy komplexebb
problémákat is megoldjunk velük és sok
esetben utolérhetik vagy vagy vagy
felülmúlhatják felülmúlják ugye
sokszorosan is akár az emberi
teljesítményt olyankor amikor amikor
mondjuk úgy valamilyen logikai vagy
aritmetikai műveletekre visszavezethető
problémákról van szó de más problémák
esetében ez már jóval árnyaltabb tehát
hogyha arra gondolunk hogy egy csecsemő
már nagy bizonyossággal be tudja
azonosítani a mondjuk a saját édesanyját
vagy saját szüleit amíg a
számítógépekkel elértünk azok addig
azokik a képfel f ismerő algoritmusokig
amik ezt már többékevésbé tudták
produkálni azért odáig hosszú út
vezetett vagy vagy nem olyan egyszerű
mondjuk nem tudom egy egy robotot
megtanítani pingpangozni vagy vagy
hasonló
viszont ez mindig mindig mindig
megpróbáltuk tehát azért mondtam hogy
egy régi a gyökerek azok nagyon régre
nyúlnak vissza mert ez mindig jelen volt
gyakorlatilag hogy amióta egy
informatikáról beszélünk hogy
megpróbáljunk
ugye mesterséges
intelligenciá vagy valamilyen módon
intelligensen viselkedő rendszereket is
kidolgozni ugye itt van két fogalom ami
a ugye van a az erős mestin meg a gyenge
mestint ugye az erős mestint az amikor
már tényleg egy emberi gondolkodáshoz
hasonló gondolkodású
vagy akár azon túlmutató
és akár öntudattal rendelkező gépet
hozunk létre ez az egyik történet nem
tartunk ott de a másik vonalon ugye ami
arról szól ez a il mesint hogy konkrét
problémák megoldására tudjunk egy adott
probléma megoldására tudjunk ki találni
összerakni egy mondjuk akár tanulni
képes és valamilyen módon
szempontból mesterségesen viselkedő
algoritmus ilyen szempontból már nagyon
rég vannak végül is eredményeink és a
mesterséges intelligenciának ennek a
mint tudomány terület ez is egyébként
egy nagyon szerteágazó terület tehát
nagyon sok ágaboga van most
például én ilyen szakirányú mesterit
végeztem annak idején valamikor a az
évezred elején úgyhogy volt ott nem
tudom már hány 10 plusz tantárgyunk ami
mind teljesen különböző területeket
vettek le és azt hiszem hogy még ott is
csak a a felszínét karcolgattuk a a
teljes történetnek tehát nagyon sok
alterülete is van ennek a
vagy ága van ennek a ennek a
tudományterületnek és ha a fejlődését
nézzük akkor mindig voltak ilyen
kicsúcsosodások vagy ilyen kisebb
robbanások persze a fejlődés ugyanakkor
folyamatos is volt és ráadásul már
beszéltük hogy exponenciális úgyhogy
úgyhogy hallat közben előre de mindig
voltak ilyen nem tudom ilyen ilyen ilyen
robbanás sokal már annak nevzz az előbb
tehát hogy kezdve attól hogy és nagyon
régre nyúlnak vissza a a a gyökerek
tehát igazából mindaz aminek ami ami ami
most történik annak mondjuk uggy a
matematikai alapjai tényleg ahogy
mondtad megvannak már közel 100 éve
tehát mondjuk a ugye a neurális hálók
talán gépi tanulási módszerek és ezen
belül is a neurális hálók a a
legismertebb része vagy a leg a
közbeszédbe leginkább jelenlévő része
ennek a ennek az egész történetnek
ugyeát a mesterséges ne az valam 43-baan
vezették be hogyha hogyha nem tévedek és
nagyjából akkor jöttek az első neurális
hálózatok ugye a
amiknek utána nagyon hamar és akkor volt
akkor persze egy hype hogy akkor a a
mesterséges intelligencia körül persze
ezeknek nagyon hamar kiderültek a
limitációi akkor volt egy visszaesés de
utána valamivel később ugye a 60-as
években a
több rétegű neurális hálóknak meg azz
ezek tanítására alkalmas algoritmusoknak
a bevezetésével
ugye átlép túl tudtak lépni ezen a
problémán akkor megint egy nagyobb hype
kerekedett ki a a szakma körül tehát
azért mondtam hogy mindig voltak ilyen
ilyen ilyen hullámzások robbanások most
mi történt akkor ugye a a tehát
2022-t említettél mit én mondtam hogy én
inkább 2015-16-ra datálnám a a a
robbanás é inkább 2022 az a pont amikor
ennek a nem tudom a hatása vagy a hull
ámai beértek úgymond a
publikus térbe erőteljesebben
ugye már ugye mi volt 2016-ban ugye
említettük az
alfagó mi a különbség mondjuk ahhoz
képest ami történt mondjuk 97-ben amikor
a diblu megverte kázpára volt ugye a
deblue az még egy elég klasszikus ilyen
döntési fákon alapuló algoritmust
használt
ami a sak esetében elégséges volt hogy
legyőzze akár a a világbajnokot annak
ellenére hogy a nagymesterek nem nem nem
ugyanezzel a
megközelítéssel játszanak tehát ők
sokkal inkább mintákat keresnek és
látnak egy idő után a a a táblám már nem
ez a döntésifa hogyha lépek akkor és
annak mi akkor előre gondoljuk 810
lépéssel hanem sokkal inkább mintákba
gondolkodnak de az a sima döntési fákon
alapuló megközelítés hogyha volt elég
már akkor kapacitása a számítógépnek
hogy jó néhány lépésre előre ki tudja
számolni a lehetséges
variációkat elégséges volt ahhoz hogy a
nagy egy nagymestert vagy egy vagy akár
a világbajnokot legyőzze
ugyanis a a a viszont ugyanez a
megközelítés már nem lett volna elég a
go esetében egész egyszerűen azért mert
nagyobb a játéktér a go esetében több a
lehetség lépéslehetőségek lehetséges
variációknak a száma már ez az egyszerű
döntési fákon alapuló megközelítés nem
működöt működtek viszont akkor a
neurális hálók de ehet az kellett hogy
gyakorlatilag újra felfedezzék a
neurális hálókat mondjam azt ugye ezeket
az úgynevezett ugye
mélytanulási módszereket amik olyan
hálók amik amik nagyon-nagyon sok
neuronból nagyonnagyon sok ilyen
mesterséges idegsejtből nagyon sok
rétegből tevődnek össze nagyon nagy a
komplexitásuk miért nem használtunk
azelőtt is már ilyeneket egész
egyszerűen azért mert vagy mi miért
miért kellett kivárni ezt a pontot hogy
hogyha már meg vololtak a a matematikai
hátterünkk egész egyszerűen nem volt meg
még a a a számítási kapacitásunk amihez
ehhez egyrészt ami ami szükséges volt
ehhez nem volt meg hozzá a a a hardver
ez ez mostanra beérett tehát hogy most
már van elég számítási kapacitás és a
másik hugye ami ami kell ezekhez a
mesterséges m intelligencia modellekhez
ami ami nagyon fontos ami nélkül nem
működnek az mindig az adat ugye ezt egy
kollég nagyon jól megfogalmazta hogy a
mesterséges intelligencia adatok nélkül
vak és most értünk el odáig hogy
rendelkezésünkre álljon elegendő adat
ami szükséges ezeknek a modelleknek a
hatékony tanításához úgyhogy
gyakorlatilag azon a ponton a 15 16-ban
ugye ezeknek a összetett
neurális hállóknak a bevezetésével és
ezeknek a tanulási módszereknek a
bevezetésével amire mondtam hogy úgymond
egyú új löketet kapott ez az egész
ágazat ez a gépi tanulás neurális hállók
ágazata ez volt egy nagyon fontos
kiindulópont és ehhez még hozzájárult
valami azon a ponton ami azelőtt szintén
nem történt meg hogy több nagy vállalat
beállt az ilyen jellegű
alapkutatások mögé és az történt hogy
nagyon sok vállalat adott ki bárki
számára hozzáférhető technológiákat amik
nagyon megkönnyítették hogy ilyen
modellekkel operál vagy akár modelleket
amik bárki számára
hozzáférhetőek következményként hirtelen
nagyon sokan kezdtek el foglalkozni
könnyebbé vált a belépési szint és
nagyon sokan kezdtek el ezzel
foglalkozni nagyon intenzívvé váltak a
területen belüli kutatások és hát ez
vezetett ahhoz hogy gyakorlatilag
percenként jöttek a jöttek az új
eredmények sok egyéb lépcsőfokon
keresztül el például 2022-ben ugye a
nagy nyelvi modellek népszerűségének a
robbanásáig ami már ami már könnyebben
bekerülhetett a köztudatba tehát itt
most már olyan rendszerekről beszélünk
amivel nem feltétlenül csak a a szakma
hanem egy egy egy egy egy laikus is
könnyen el tud el tud beszélgetni ami
már mondjuk úgy szinte emberi módon tud
vele kommunikálni és ez vezetett ahhoz a
ahhoz hogy ez a köztudatba is ennyire
erőteljesen berobbant ez a ez a
mesterséges igen tát ez hogy
gyakorlatilag bárki tudja használni
képzés nélkül ez ez ez egy ez ez a az
egyik oka és úyahogy mondtad a másik két
okot amit megemlítettél hogy az a
számítási kapacitás és információhalmaz
ami szükséges volt erre habár az
elméleti háttér megvolt a gyakorlat az
az most érett be az elmúlt időszakban és
tényleg valami hihetetlen dolog történik
mert mert nem csak arra használjuk hogy
beszélgetünk vele nem csak verset
generáltatunk ezzel hanem a a most én a
a nagynyelvi modellekre értem és a chat
gpt-re meg a a google-nek a bárgjára
hanem hanem ez lassan át fogja alakítani
azt hogy hogyan dolgozunk már most
átalakítja hogy hogyan dolgozunk egy
emailt hogyan írunk meg hogyan
gondolkozunk én nap mint nap használom
arra hogy hogy segítsen felgyorsítani a
gondolkodási folyamatomat ha valami
komplex dologról gondolkodok akkor
együtt gondolkodok vele segít abban hogy
hogy desztiláljam a gondolataimat tehát
hogyha a fejemben ott van mint emberként
és még minden embernek a az a kaotikus
gondolatsor ami valami ami új területtel
kapcsolatos akkor nagyon segít engem
abban hogy hogy letisztítsa és csak az
ég tudja hogy mennyi mindenre lehet még
használni úgyhogy számomra ez egy
izgalmas lehetőség viszont megemlítettél
egy másik dolgot is hogy mint az
emberiség történelmében minden
eszköz ami segít minket van egy olyan
tendenciája és viszont hogy gyengébbé is
tesz minket tehát minden egyes
technológiai vívmány most tegyük fel az
oltás ott van hogy hogy oltás nélkül
meghalunk
viszont az oltással gyengébbé válunk a
minden egyes gyógyszer ugyanakkor megvéd
de gyengébbé is teszi az
immunrendszerünket mert nem küzd meg az
immunrendszerünk azzal a betegséggel de
ez ugyanígy van a a az összes géppel
hogy ki az aki ha most minden gépünket
elvennék abban a pillanatban nem tudom
itt legalábbis székelyföldön egy telet
végig tudnánk-e élni és és mi fog jönni
tehát ez ez a félelem implicit benne van
az emberekben hogy ha minden felgyorsul
és egyre több mindent várnak el tőlünk
akkor mi fog történni akkor hogyha
valaki ezt nem fogja tudni használni e
ez ez ez lemarad ez a személy és it még
egy másik gondolatot elmondané kíváncsi
vagyok a véleményedre
hogy az emberiség tehát az iq az egyik
legbiztosabb
ilyen előrejelzője a a szakmai sikernek
tehát hogy ez ez egy
nagyon
nagyon fájdalmas információ de tényleg
az van hogy akikn magasabb az úja
statisztikailag könnyebben boldogulnak a
világban és ez ez úgy is megjelenik hogy
például a hadsereg 83 iq alatt már nem
vesz be senkit a az amerikai hadseregről
beszélek azért 83 mert azt látták hogy
83 iq alatt nem tudnak semmi olyan
munkát adni annak a személynek hogy hogy
azt produktívan el tudja végezni és ez
egy nagyon fájdalmas kutatási eredmény
mert egyrészt nem szívesen hallja ezt
senki és a másik pedig az hogy nem
tudunk mit kezdeni ezzel is az
embereknek a ti pár%záaléka 83 i alatt
van ez egy az ik az egy természetes
eloszlást mutat tehát ez a gaus görb az
a harangőrbe ki lehet számolni elég
pontosan azt hogy káb hány embernek van
100 a közepe amúgy az iq-nak és káb ki
lehet számolni azt hogy 83 i alatt hány
ember van és azt látom hogy ahogy a
világunk egyre gyorsabbá válik és egyre
komplexebbé válik talán ez a belépési
küszöb egyre magasabban lesz tehát már
lehet nem lesz elegendő 83 mikor 8485-re
lesz szükség ha most az ördög ügyvédjét
kell játszam így a technológiával
szemben akkor ez lenne az egyik pont ami
ami ami megkérdezném a te véleményedet
hogy vajon neme azt fogja okozni hogy
egyre nagyobb réteg lesz az aki viszont
nem fog tudni a versenyszférába labdába
rúgni mert túl sok túl komplexzé válik a
világunk és egy szűk kisebbsége a az
emberiségnek hiperproduktív lesz aki
eddig is produktív volt az még
produktívabbá válik még több mindent el
fog tudni végezni és és egy egy egy
egyre nagyobb és növekvő kisebbség mert
azért még mindig kisebbség egyre jobban
ki lesz téve annak hogy már nem nagyon
fog tudni mit csinálni mert nem lesz
munka
számára hm hát a a a kérdésedben azt
hiszem hogy implicit az is benne van
hogy akkor
hogyan hogy hogy mi a mi lenne az
esztimáció vagy az előrejelzés hogy
hogyan fogja igazából a munkaerőpiacot
átalakítani ez a abszolút ez az ai hogy
akkor tényleg az lesz-e hogy akkor
megszűnnek
munkakörök vagy pont hogy több m több
több munkahely fog igen hogy hogy azok
amik megjelennek újak azok azok tényleg
ilyen magasabb bíkú vagy magasabb
szakmai felkészültséget fognak-e
igényelni én azt gondolom hogy ez egy ez
egy ez egy összetettebb dolog és sok
szempontból árnyalatabb mertogy hogy
hogy hogy függ attól hogy melyik milyen
munkakörre milyen hatással lesz tehát a
a értelemszerűen lesz át fogja alakítani
a már r átalakította és ugyanúgy ahogy
eddig is átalakította a technológiai
fejlődés a munkaerőpiacot ugyanígy át
fogja alakítani a következőkben is és
ilyen szempontból persze az ai-nak is
megvan és meglesz a
az impaktja most milyen munkakörök
fognak megszűnni tehát alapból azt
tudjuk mondani hogy azok a munkakörök
amelyek könnyebben automatizálhatóak
tehát például amik valamilyen repetitív
ismételhető
munkáró szólnak azok nagyobb eséllyel
lesznek ugye robotizálva vagy
helyettesítve
robotok
által de ez nem feltétlenül jelenti
egyrész hogy hogy ezzel együtt meg
fognak jelenni teljesen új munkakörök
amiket most még nem is feltétlenül
tudunk pontosan hogy azok hogy fognak
kinézni másrészt ez egyáltalán nem azt
jelenti hogy akkor most csak a nem tudom
a magas felkészültségű get igénylő nem
tudom hogy értelmiségi szakmák maradnak
meg és akkor a másik oldalról tehát
mondjuk ugy a kék galéros vonalról
tűnnek el a sőt sőt tehát hogy
és nem is egyik napról a másikra fog
azért ez ez ez ez
bekövetkezni én próbálnék egy picit
ilyen optimistább nézőpontot képviselni
ugye annak idején is nagy
felháborodás egészen tüntetésekig
elmenő felháborodás övezte ugye a
mosógépek mosógép megjelenését ugye
akkor is soknan azt vizionálták hogy
akkor eznek most nagyon óriási
társadalmi impaktja lesz megszűnnek a
munkahelyek moson munkahelyei és és és
és akkor olyan hogy mi lesz és és és
való igaz megszűntek de megjelentek újra
tehát átalakult tudott alkalmazkodni a a
társadalom én nagyon remélem vagy merem
remélni hogy a ez a technológiával é a
mesterséges intelligenciával is ugyanígy
fog történni csak ez nem fog magától
történni tehát ehhez nekünk tennünk kell
hogy itt
itt tudjunk úgymond adaptálódni igen át
fog alakulni a munkaerőpiac de most
néhány évvel ezelőtt amikor amikor
megjelentek az első automata nem tudom
kasszák vagy akár full automatizált
teljesen automatizált üzletek akkor
akkor akkor mindenki azt vizionálta hogy
akkor most nem lesz szükség
kasasszásokra az üzletekbe nem ez
történt igaz megjelentek a a az
automatizált terminálok és igen
megjelentek teljesen automatizált
üzletek de továbbra is szüksé csak
szükség van a az emberi jelenlétre az
önvezető autók környékén amikor nagyon
hype volt néhány évvel ezelőtt egyébként
itt is egy zárójelként igazából megint
az hogye azt mondtuk hogy régre nyúlnak
vissza a gyökerek mer a 80-as években is
intenzíven kutatták az önvezető autókat
sőt már 80-as években volt
működő neurális hálózat által vezetett
ön önvezető autó igaz hogy még jó nagy
volt szegény mert sok hardwt rá kellett
pakolni és igaz hogy még csak egy előre
kijelőlt pályán tudott menni nagyon
kicsi sebességgel tehát semmiképpen nem
összehasonlítható a mai technológiával
de már ott megvoltak a gyökerei ezeknek
a történeteknek zárójel bezárva
visszatérve ugye az önvezető autóknak a
fejlődésével ugye vizionálták hogy
néhány év múlva már nem lesz szükség
sofőrökre elérhetünk addig a pont
ameddig kevesebbre lesz szükség tehát
amikor tényleg logisztikában
szállításban is elterjedtebb lesz már a
mesterséges de még de még nem tartunk
ott és nem egyik napról a másikra fog ez
lezajlani egyébként van egy ilyen
weboldal is az érdekesség kedvére hogy a
a mondom itt a hallgatóknak hogyha meg
akarják nézni akkor van egy ilyen hogy
hogy hogy elveszik-e a robotok a
munkahelyinket munkas akkor ez különböző
ilyen valószínűséget számít nem tudom
pontosan a módszertan mi alapján
gyanítom hogy visszajelzések tehát hogy
felhasználói feedbackek alapján hogy
akkor mennyi a valószínűsége hogy hogy
elveszük elvesztem az adott munka
körömet a mesterséges intelligencián a
de ez is ha néha megnézed ezt a
weboldalt nagyon változó n v most
például jelen pillanatban nagyjából azt
látnánk rajta hogy az informatikusok
vannak a a legnagyobb veszélyben
és ez ez sem és és vannak olyanok akik
tényleg azt mondják hogy hát itt két
éven belül már nem lesz szükség
programozókra mert mindent a
azér fog megírni én ezt is árnyaltabbá
látom árnyaltabbnak látom tehát
igen meglesz a a az impaktja a
történeten de nem az ez nem azt jelenti
hogy akkor kész nincsen szükségünk
programozókra utána nincsen szükségünk
architektekre nincsen szükségünk emberi
jelenlétre hogyha belegondolunk
egyébként már 20 évvel ezelőtt is vagy
30 évvel ezelőtt is voltak olyan
eszközeink amelyek hatékonyabbá tették a
munkánkat akárhogy csak a saját
munkánknál mondjuk a programozásnál
informatikánál maradok ugye jelentek meg
a jobbnál fejlesztői környezetek amik
hatékonyabbnár kényelmesebbé tették a
fejlesztést utána meg jelentek már vagy
használtunk már tizen évvel ezelőtt is
olyan automatizált kógenerátor
eszközöket amelyek gyakorlatilag egy
teljes projektvázát tudták nekünk
automatikusan generálni tehát az
egyszerű rutin feladatoknál tudták
helyettesíteni a programozót
de példaként hogy ez ezekre én a a a
tanítványoknak aoktatásban is mindig azt
mondom hogy ezek ezek nem ördögvó
ördögtől valóak ezek a ső sőt ezek azok
azért voltak kitalálva hogy a munkánkat
hatékonyabbá tegyék akkor használjuk
ezeket de csak akkor használjunk egy
ilyen eszközt hogyha értjük hogy hogy
hogyan működik tehát például akkor
használjunk egy kódgenerátor eszközt
amikor megértettük azt a kódot amit
tehát a mesterévé vált váltunk annak
amit kigeneráltát is meg tudunk írni egy
ilet hanem hanem akkor elvesztődtünk
hanem akkor amikor utána azt módosítani
kell vagy amikor be kell nyúlni úgymond
a motorháztető alá akkor akkor nem lesz
mit mit tennünk tehát hogy attól
függetlenül hogy ezek az eszközök
hatékonyabbá kényelmes bé teszik a
munkánkat attól függetlenül nekünk még
szükségünk van a tudásra sőt még többre
van szükségünk hogy értsük azt hogy hogy
hogy mi van ezeknek a hátterébe hogy
megfelelően tudjuk használni ezeket és
ezek ezek tényleg eszközök legyenek a
kezünkben amik hatékonyabbá teszik a a
teszik a a munkánkat most igen ez azt
fogja jelenteni
hogy többet tehát hogy hatékonyabb
eszközeink vagyunk vannak akkor többet
tudunk több munkát tudunk elvégezni és
akkor a kérdésedre visszatérve akkor ez
azt jelenti hogy hogy hogy kevesebb
lesz-e a munkaerő vagy csökken-e ezáltal
a munkaerő igény vagy akármilyen
esélyeik vannak akkor a mondjuk a
mondjuk a junioroknak
ilyen szempontból én az azt gondolom
hogy lesz egy impaktja vagy van már és
lesz egy impaktja ennek a ennek a
történetnek de
de szerintem stabilizálódni is fog tehát
pont azért mert megjelennek teljesen új
munkakörök is ezáltal
én azt gondolom hogy mindenki meg tudja
találni a a helyét hogyha odafigyel erre
arra hog odafigyel erre tiszta és
világos szerintem hogy itt itt egy
kicsit tehát hogy hogy rengeteg
tanulásra van szükségess egy kicsit
másfajta kompetenciák kerülnek előtérbe
mint mondjuk régen gondolok itt arra
hogy nagyon-nagyon fontos lesz az hogy
hogy hogy hogy adaptálódni tudjunk
ezekhez a nagyon nagyon nagyon gyors
válto változásokhoz
ö nagyon-nagyon szükséges lesz az hogy
hogy hogy csapatban tudjunk dolgozni
hogy hogy az együttműködés kultúráját
úgymond úgymond megértsük és és
alkalmazzuk a a kommunikációnak a
kreatív ágazatoknak a ez a stem vagy
steam ez a science technology
engineeringen met ágazatoknak tehát
ezeknek lesz kiemelt vagy ezeknek már
kiemelt a jelentősége ilyen ilyen
szempontból hogy tudjunk alkalmazkodni
ezekhez a folyamatokhoz ezekhez a
változásokhoz é erről egy kicsit még
akarok beszélgetni
a még birkózhatnánk amúgy hogye az
ördögügyvégyet játszam még birkózhatnánk
azzal hogy én mondom a a a félelmeimet
és te megnyugtatsz engem de s inkább
összefoglalnám hogy mi a a a
gondolatodnak é az érvednek az alapja és
hogyha egyetérrtünk akkor tovább tudok
menni én azt érzem hogy hogy az alapvető
hozzáállásod az ami az emberiségnek az
alapvető hozzáállása volt a a a
történelem kaotikus forgatagán ak mindig
jöttek új dolgok mindig jöttek valami
mindig jöttek olyan dolgok amik
egyszerűen a megszokott rendet
felborították és valahogy mindig meg
tudta oldani az emberiség kollektívan
kitaláltuk és a bizonytalanságot együtt
kreatívan megoldottuk de ennek vannak
feltételei az egyik az éberség amit
mondtál hogy folyamatosan éberen
figyeljünk hogy adaptálódjunk a
folyamatos tanulás és és bizonyos
kvalitásoknak a a a tehát egy egy egy
felébredés valójában amikor autom a
izáltan éljük az életünket akkor kicsit
minthogyha elaludna az emberiség
automatizálttá válna és és megszokottá
ilyenkor amikor egy krízishelyzet ér
minket akkor kollektívan felébredünk és
egyrészt rájövünk arra hogy ezt akkor
tudjuk legyőzni hogyha együtt vagyunk
benne tehát hogy az indivídum önmagáb
túl kevés ahhoz hogy ezt legyőzze tehát
szükség van a közösségre a
kollaborációra az éberségre az alázatra
mert valójában önmagunk azt jelenti az
alázat hogy én nem tudok eleget ahhoz
hogy kitaláljam a világunkat és bizonyos
új kvalitásokra úgyhogy ugye a
bóogatásokból azt láttam hogy eddig
akkor nyomon vagyunk rendben vagyunk
nagyon szépen összefoglaltod köszönöm
szépen nagyszerű örvendek akkor kicsit
beszéljünk arról hogy a jövő amit látsz
magad előtt erről hogyan tud felkészülni
valaki és mire készüljön fel hogyan kéne
használja ezeket az ai eszközöket
nyilván most tapogatunk a jövőben egy
olyan helyen ahol ahol te sem tudhatod
ezeket én sem tudhatom de gondolkozzunk
rajta hogy mit fog ez okozni hogyan
alakul át majd a munkánk a nap mintnap
munkánk és hogyan kell használjuk az ai
eszközöket manapság hát hogyha egy picit
általánosabban hogy hogyan kell
használjuk egy egyáltalán a digitális
vagy technológiai eszközöket és itt
akkor gondolom hogy itt most
átlagfelhasználóként teljesen
általánosan átl gondolkodunk itt amire
amire nagyon nagy szükségünk van
szerintem az a tudatosság tehát hogy
tudatosan használjuk ezeket és ehhez van
szükségünk arra hogy hogy hogy hogy
tanuljunk szükség van arra amit
éberségnek
neveztél hogy
hogy odafigyeléssel körültekintően és
nyitottsággal álljunk ezekhez a ezekhez
az eszközökhöz tanuljuk meg ezeknek a
használatát tudatos
használatát ennél jobban konkretizálni
nem tudom hogy tudom-e mert nagyon függ
attól hogy hogyan hogy hogy ezen
túlmutatóan ez az alap és hogy ezen
túlmutatóan hogyan használjuk őket az
már eléggé függ attól hogy milyen milyen
doméniumba dolgozunk és milyen doméniumb
ak e mondok konkrétan egy gondolatos
lássam mi a vélemény erről az az érzésem
hogy pont amiatt mert minden ami
automatizálható bennünk tehát azok a
dolgok amikre képes az ember de gépi
tehát vannak gépi képességeink hogy
repetitíven tudunk csinálni dolgokat
ezeket ezeket fogja is automatizálni a a
jövőben valamilyen rendszer emiatt
minden ami emberi bennünk ami ami minket
nem gépivé hanem emberivé tesz fel fog
erősödni például az egyik tendencia amit
látok az pont a podcast hogy a podcast
az egy abszolút emberi műfaj két ember
ül le és beszélget és kollektívan
gondolkozik valamiről sőt az élő
változata a podcastnek amikor live
streambbe megy és ennek a változata
például a koncert tehát nem egy stúdió
felvételnek lesz azérr tehát edig eddig
értékes volt egy stúdió felvétel de
egyre inkább maga a koncertnek a a a a
megélése hogy helyben ott vagy és és
hallod a pontatlanságát azoknak a
hangszereknek tehát egyszerre pontos és
egyszerre érzed azt hogy ez ez ez mégse
félisten játsszák hanem vannak apró mikr
hibák amik emberivé tesznek minket és
egyszerre van jelen a az a csodálatos
képessége az embernek hogy hogy valami
hihetetlen dolgot hozzon létre úgy hogy
nem felejtjük el közben hy azért mégis
csak törékenyek vagyunk és mulandóak
vagyunk úgyhogy minden ami emberi az fel
fog erősödni és ezt is említettük
valójában hogy a home officezal
eltávolodtunk egymástól de mennyire
felerősödött már az hogyha
találkozhatunk tehát egy-egy csapatépítő
mennyire értékessé válik és én ezt amúgy
egyre inkább tapasztalom hogy ha egy új
klienssel leülök tárgyalni ha előtte
személyesen találkozok vele teljesen más
utána a veleevó munka a következő pár
hétben vagy akár pár hónapba minthogyha
végig csak skype-on keresztül beszéltünk
volna és csak egy ilyen egy ilyen
négyzeten keresztül láttam volna az
arcát van valami ami ami a személyes
találkozást nem pótolhatja ami ami a
tekintetben van benne a testbeszédben
van benne felerősödnek azok a kvalitások
amelyek a a diplomáciával kapcsolatosak
a a a a kapcsolatteremtéssel a
házigazdasággal és ezt érzem is hogy van
ennek van egy olyan bölcsesség ebben az
it klaszterben ami amit ugyancsak
általad értettem meg hogy van benne egy
mély bölcsesség hogy meginvitáljunk
embereket és időt töltsünk el együtt
egy-két napot és és beszélgessünk mert
nem a és nem az információról szól tehát
maga az az információ amelyik elhangzik
egy konferencián sosem a az információ a
lényeg mer azt fel tudjuk keresni bármik
akkor már bárki elérheti ezt egy telefon
telefonon keresztül nem az információ a
lényeg nem azért találkozunk egy
konferencián hogy feltétlenül hogy
tanuljunk valami ez a kicsi része a nagy
része az a a kávészünet az ebédszünet az
esti beszélgetések a a networking része
amikor az emberek találkoznak egymással
kezet tudnak fogni és és és beszélgetni
tudnak egymással úgyhogy úgyhogy azt
hiszem hogy e az ai talán pont ezt fogja
hozni bennünk hogy minden ami ami nem
feltétlenül emberi bennünk azt tudjuk
delegálni nem minden hanem hogy egyre
több mindent fog tudnun delegálni
egy-egy emailnek a megírását amiben az a
lényeget el tudjuk mondani de ő majd
szépen nekünk kiegészíti hogy olyan
formája legyen hogy hogy az ember elé
való és nem egy órát töltünk azzal az
emaillel hanem öt percet töltünk a a az
emaillel úgyhogy valami ilyesmit láttok
én kíváncsi vagyok a véleményedre hogy
hogy mostantól kezdve kell foglalkozzunk
azokkal a dolgokkal amik minket emberré
tesznek például a steamet említett de
amikor a a a a a különböző disciplinákat
említetted a steamen belül az arartsot
kifelejtetted most így úgyhogy külön azt
megemlíteném hogy a steam az a science
technology engineering arts and
mathematicsnek a rövidítése ez a steam
oktatás egy kicsit akár mesélhetnél is
róla mert ez egy közös ügyünk is hogy
hogy kis otthonunkban steam oktatás
egyre inkább hangsúlyban legyen tehát
hogy az arts része az amikor az emberek
azzal foglalkoznak ami a a a a mert mi
is a művészi a művészi az hogy valami
olyan dologgal foglalkozunk ami pont a
határainkat súrolja ami a a az
érzékelési határunkat amikor amikor
nincsenek szavaink csak érzéseink vannak
de megpróbáljuk azt a valamit megfogni
és valahogy valamilyen formában
egységesíteni egy kép formájáb egy egy
egy szobor formájáb egy egy dalformájáb
és én azt én én nagyon nagyon nagy
rajongója vagyok a művészeteknek olyan
szempontból hogy tényleg azt látom hogy
a művészek azok akik megtanítanak minket
látni megtanítak érzékelni érzékelni a
világot egyre inkább és és talán ez fel
fog erősödni hogyha az optimista
oldalamat keresem pont az hogy mivel
mindent ki tud bennünk váltani vagy a
legtöbb dolgot ki tudja bennünk váltani
ami nem emberi emiatt feltőr majd egy
emberi oldal is ami egyre inkább ér
fontos lesz és és és értékes lesz azt
mondad hogy te leszel az ördög ügyvégye
de ez egy teljesen optimista
igen lezártam ott mert azt láttam még
tudnánk birkózni de igazából izgalmasabb
számomra hogy nem nem nem nem azokkal
birkózok am én nagyon egyetértek azzal
amit ö amit elmondtál
ezúan is bocs hogy kihagytam az előbb a
az a betűt a steamből ugye ezt szokták
stemnek steamnek nagyon-nagyon fontos és
és és
[Zene]
nagyon egyetértek így legyen hogy
tényleg a a az hogy a hogy megspórol
nekünk időt energiát megspórolnak ezek a
technológiák vagy akár a mesterséges
intelligencia azáltal hogy így ahogy
mondod el végzi helyettünk a a a rutin
feladatokat ez nagyon obb teret adhat
majd a kreativitásunknak nagyobb teret
adhat majd a személyes találkozásoknak
ötleteléseknek beszélgetéseknek
kapcsolatterteremtésnek így legyen
a a mentorprogram is a a az
átképzés programjában benne van-e az ai
ebben a pillanatban az átképzés
programjában jelen pillanatban nincs
benne mint tantárgy pont azért mert már
egy szakosodás irányába mutats vagy mond
ez az átképzési program ez inkább tehát
e eg szoftverfejlesztési átképzés és
kimondottan ilyen szoftverfejlesztéssel
kapcsolatos tárgyak kerülnek bele de még
egyszer mondom hogy az alapok azok
adottak a miután valaki elvégezte ezt a
képzést hogyha mondjuk el akar egy ai
szakosodás irányába indulni akkor ezt
megteheti
a mentorprogramjainknak magának a ugye
az a kis ilyen
összetettebb programok azokról nem
beszéltem nagyon röviden itt kétféle
mentorprogramunk van van egy a
középiskolás amit középiskolások számára
szervezünk az arról szól hogy
tudatosabban tehát a mi részünkről
értelemszerűen az lenne a jó hogyha
minél többen választanák tovább tanulás
szempontjából ezt a szakmát az
informatikát vagy valami ehhez
kapcsolódó területet de ami mindenképpen
célunk hogy tudatosabban történjen ez a
választás tehát olyan dolgokat próbálunk
nekik megmutatni amik valamilyen szinten
túlmutatnak a középiskolástan anyagon
ami egyébként nagyon-nagyon fontos
alaprésze a szakmának amit ott ők
tanulnak viszont önmagában talán
elmondhatjuk hogy egy kicsit száraz ö mi
ezt szeretnénk kiegészíteni megmutatni a
nekik azt hogy
egy picit pici rálátást adni hogy hogy
hogy miről szól a a szakma azért hogy
tudatosabban t tudjanak utána pályát
választani ennek is részét képezik
képzések részét képezik ilyen cégekkel
közös gyakorlati tevékenységek ami ennek
a úgymond a a nagy testvére vagy aminek
ez a kistestvére az ugye a a az
egyetemista mentorprogramunk aminek
aminek az a célja hogy már az alapképzés
ideje alatt az egyetemisták
hát egyrészt hogyha mondjuk udvarhi
viszonylatba nézzük akkor tudjanak a
helyi cégekről látható legyen számukra
is látható legyen nem tudom például
kolozsvárról is az egyetemisták számára
hogy itt vannak vagány cégek szép
projektek jó karrierlehetőségek tudjanak
eljönni megismerkedni ezekkel a cégekkel
és utána tartsunk fel velük egy
folyamatos kapcsolatot egészen az
egyetem
tehát az alapképzés lezárásáig am mi
szempontunkból miért mert akkor nagyobb
eséllyel fognak majd ezeknek a cégeknek
a
csapataihoz csatlakozni és ugye az it az
az tipikusan az a terület ahol nem a vas
meg a beton a jelenti a sikertitkát
hanem a szellemi tőke a szürkeállomány
tehát gyakorlatilag a munkatársaknak a
tudását és az idejét visszük a piacra
úgyhogy ilyen szempontból nagyon fontos
hogy meglegyen a
megfelelő humán erőforrás utánpótlás is
na most visszatérve a kérdésedre ez a
mentorprogram is önmagában egy egy
összetettebb történet ami ugye több
szempontból túlmutat egy ilyen
klasszikus szakmai gyakorlat vagy
internship programon tehát részét
képzezi képzés is részét képezi szakmai
gyakorlat tudományos diák köri
konferenciákra visszük a diákcsapatokat
mentorok irányítása alatt jellemzően itt
a cégeknél csapatokban kis csapatokban
dolgoznak államvizsg dolgozatok
készülnek és így tovább tehát több része
van ennek a történetnek most a képzés
részében ami azt az egészet megalapozza
hogy választ adjak a konkrét kérdésre de
ott szintén nem része magának a
képzésnek a a mesterséges intelligenciá
mert ott olyan dolgokra próbáljuk tehát
a képzés résznek az a az a lényege ennek
a programnak az esetében hogy
megtanítsunk nekik olyan
szoftverfejlesztési módszereket mintákat
recepteket és persze ezeket valamilyen
technológiákkal is szemléltessük
amelyeket ők azonnal tudnak utána már a
szakmai gyakorlat során alkalmazni és a
mentoraik gyakorlatilag nem kell
mindenkinek külön-külön ezeket ezeket
ezeket megmutassák
egyrészt másrészt tudják azokat az
eszközöket módszereket megközelítéseket
alkalmazni amihez egyébként ők hozzá
vannak szokva a mindennapi munkájuk
során az éles projektek esetében is és
így tudunk ezekkel a diákcsapatokkal
olyan szempontból szép eredményeket
elérni hogy akkor tényleg szép kerek
történetek sülnek ki ezekből a
a projektekből kis szoftver prototípusok
amiket utána tényleg hatásosan be lehet
mutatni mondjuk egy diákköri
konferencián vagy egy egy
államvizsgavédés keretein belül tehát
szintén a képzés része az inkább
szoftverfejlesztési módszerekről szól
ennek a mentorprogramnak viszont a
projektekben már igen is jelen van a a
mesterséges intelligenciá tehát hogy itt
ez nagyon függ attól hogy milyen típusú
mer ugye kis csapatok különböző
projekteken dolgoznak de elég sok olyan
jellegű
prototípust fejlesztettek a diákok az
előző években ami amelyeknél elég
hangsúlyos szerepet kap ez a mesterséges
intelligenciaavonal
így így most az merült fel bennem mint
kérdés hogy tudsz-e itt
székelyudvarhelyén olyan képzést ami a a
chat gpt alapjait mutatja be a
hétköznapi embernek hogyha valaki
megszeretné tanulni de fogalma sincs
hogy hol kezdje és fél attól fél mert
sosem nagyon sosem használta ezeket az
eszközöket az átlagfelhasználónak valami
tudsz egy ilyen lehetőségről olyan
rendezvényszerűen megszervezetett
képzésekről láttam amik amik talán
kicsit nem hogy is mondjam nem tudom
doménpecifikusabbak voltak hogy inkább
nem tudom vál volt olyan ami
vállalkozóknak szólt vagy volt olyan ami
marketingeseknek
szólt ilyen jellegűeket láttam most
konkrétan
címeket vagy előadókat nem szeretnék
mondani hogy nehogy nehogy tévedjek
ilyen általános általános képzés én
személy szerint nem láttam hogy hogy
hirdettek h lehet ez az amiről majd kell
beszélgessünk ezután az ignis keretén
belül lehet hogy akkor jó lenne
elindítani egy amúgy a hallgató kedvéért
már azt hiszem egy másik adásban
említettem hogy az ignis az egy oktatási
központ amit a a ünk hozott létre és a
célja hát gyakorlatilag stratégikusan
úgy illik bele hogy minden amivel ti nem
foglalkoztok azzal megpróbálunk mi
foglalkozni tehát hogy ti inkább
akadémiaibb és és specializáltabb egy
szűkebb elitnek a az
elitoktatását biztosítjátok ami nehezebb
drágább és és komplexebb és megpróbáltuk
akkor kiegészíteni ezt ezt az oktatást
azok számára is tehát nyugdíjasok
számára indítottunk képzéseket meg elemi
iskolásoknak meg 5-8-asoknak tanít tunk
programozási alapokat robotika alapokat
úgyhogy elektronikai alapokat talán itt
most így felcsillant így bennem hogy
hogy jó lenne elindítsunk egy egy alap
chat
gpt képzést ahol megtanulhatja a
hétköznapi ember is hogy mikre tudja
használni és tegyük fel három alkalomból
már a produktivitása sokkal nagyobb lesz
mert elég sok mindent meg lehet azért
tanítani ebbe a a a három alkalmas
úgyhogy most erről majd akkor fogunk
beszélgetni zárásként arra gondoltam
hogy
beszélgessünk egy kicsit a
közéleti szerepedről is mégpedig a a
következő önkormányzati csapatnak a
tagja leszel és ez bizonyos szempontból
egy nagy lehetőség is a kezedben hogy
ezt a fajta stratégikus látásmódot amit
így a digitális stratégia által az it
claster által így így így látsz és és és
a kapcsolati tőkéd ami ami eddig
felépült ezt ezt arra használjuk hogy
hogy hogy egy következő szintre lépjen a
városunk digitális
stratégiája milyen terveid vannak ezzel
kapcsolatban hogy látod a következő négy
évet milyen potenciál van most így a a
ami előttünk van mi rejlik a négy évben
ühüm egy kicsit erre a digitális
stratégiára reflektálva csak reflektálok
az előbb átugrottuk aztán a át átmentünk
egy másik témára most azért csak
elmondanék egy-két gondolatot ugye itt
nagyon sok minden amiről mi eddig a
diekben ezen a beszélgetés beszélgettünk
mer amiről szó volt azok a kimondottan
az it szektor
fejlztésérőlel szólnak én inkább úgy
közelíteném meg a például amit ahogy
mondtad az az ignis programjai versus a
clasternek a programjaai is hogy és
egyébként nagyon nagyon nagyon nagy
érték az amit ti a az
ignisszel létrehozhatok hogy ehhez csak
gratulálni tudok inkább arról szól hogy
ti egy nagyobb lefedést biztosítotok ez
által projektá mi pedig a ugye az
említett képzések által kimondottan
informatik kár a kimondott a
szoftverfejlesztésre erre fókuszálni
tehát az inkább egy ilyen egy ilyen
szakirányú képzés és mindkettőre
szükség van mindkettőnek megvan a helye
na most visszatérve akkor egy kicsit a
digitális stratégiára én is így külön
választanám azt hogyogy a hogy amikor
egy nem tudom már egy város vagy egy
közösség szintjén beszélünk digitális
stratégiáról akkor ugye nem csak arról
szól ez a történet van egy rész ugye
hogy a amiről most szó volt inkább hogy
az it helyi it szektor fejlesztése de
van egy másik oldala is ennek a úgymond
az általános digitalizáció ami persze a
kettő összefügg de de azért venném én
ezt mégis külön mert most elképzelhető
mondjuk egy olyan város ahol vannak
nagyon vagány it cégek akik külföldre
külföldi partnereknek gyártanak
valamilyen vállalati szoftvereket de
ettől még nem biztos hogy az a abból a
városból egyik napról a másikra egyik
napról a másikra egy smart city válik
lehet nagyobb az esélye de a kettő azért
két két kéz a kézben jár de attól
függetlenül két külön történet most
digitális stratégiára hogy hogy legyen
egyik szempontból és másik szempontból
hogy ez mit jelent és miért van szükség
tehát hogy ha a a szektor fejlődéséről
beszélünk akkor ott miért van szükség
tehát hogy hogy miért nem elég az hogy
vannak cégek aztán azt hiszem hogy erő
beszélgettünk a rezervátumá válás
igenal kapcsolatan tehát fejlődnünk kell
és igen egész egyszerűen azért mert
vannak olyan tehát hogyha és itt egy
nagyon fontos azért megemlíteni mint
klastert emlegettünk eddig de itt van
egy dolog amit még nem említettünk meg
ami például udvarhelyi vonatkozásban
nagyon fontos hogy itt
udvarhelyen már 2017 óta van egy
önkormányzati kezdeményezésű it
fejlesztési program ami kimondottan az
it szektor fejlődését facilitálja de
hogy hogy miért van szükség ilyen
programokra miért nem elég hogyha a
cégek önállóan végzik a a feladatokat
például azért ami ami amit mondtam hogy
ugye a ha egy város úgymond labdába
szeretne rúgni ezen a ezen a területen
és és miért szeretne hát összefüggésben
azon amit korábban mondtuk hogy hogy
olyan szakmai lehetőségeket és
életkörülményeket tudjon biztosítani a
fiataloknak ami ez igen ami mé megéri
visszajöenek tanulmányaik befejezése
után egy szempontból más szempontból
ugye nem csak az it de az it is
jellemzően ugye egy magas hozzá adott
értéket teremtő ágazat ami ráadásul
beszéltünk arra hogy kevéssé helyhez
kötött tehát ez egy kiugrási lehetőség
is ilyen szempontból egy kisebb városnak
is na de ugyanakkor a az it központok
azért a nagyobb városokban az egyetemi
központokban alakulnak ki most hogyha
egy egy kisebb város ilyen szempontból
lapdába szeretne rúgni vagy akár rá akar
csatlakozni ezekre a fejlesztési
folyamatokra
szeretné hogy a vagy szeretnénk hogy
ebben a régióban is a cégek tudjanak
érvényesülni fejlődni ehhez az kell
például hogy láthatók legyenek és nekik
konkurenciáik tehát a helyi cégeknek is
akik jellemzően kisebb cégek mondjuk
összehasonlítva a nagyobb városok
nagyvállalkozásaival
nekik ugyanúgy konkurenciái ez ilyen
szempontból ezek a nagy vállalkozások is
vagy akár a külföldi nagy vállalkozások
ahhoz hogy hogy egy konkrét példá ahhoz
hogy egy egy egy fiatal hazajöjjön és
egy helyi cégnél helyezkedjen el ahhoz
kell tudjon erről a helyi cégről és kell
lássa azt hogy itt is vannak vagány
projektek vagány karrierlehetőségek és
így tovább na most különkülön ezek a
cégek például kevésbé láthatóak a
üüm a a szektoron belül viszont hogyha
már összefognak tömörülnek és ráadásul
van egy helyi program ami ezeket a
kezdeményezéseiket és projektjeiket
valamilyen szinten segíti akkor már
sokkal több mindent érhetnek el például
akkor könnyebben eljutnak egyetemi
központokba könnyebben meg tudják
mutatni a magukat a diákoknak könnyebben
tudnak szervezni egy ilyen oktatási vagy
mentorprogramot közösen mint amiről
beszéltünk az előbb ami külön-külön
megint egy kisebb cégnek valószínű hogy
nem igazán lenne lehetőség ezt
legalábbis költség hatékonyan megoldani
tehát ezért fontos az hogy legyen egy
ilyen szempontból egy egy közös
stratégia közös gondolkodás és közös
közös fejlesztés ez az egyik oldal ugye
a másik oldal az általános digitalizáció
ami ugye arról szólna hogy a már most
sokat emlegetett technológiai
fejlesztéseket digitális eszközöket
hogyan tudjuk beépíteni és használni a
hétköznapjainkba hogyan tudjuk ezek
által
kényelmesebbé hatékonyabbá tenni a
az életünket é ezáltal akkor jobb
életkörülményeket kialakítani itt kezdve
és itt sok sok mindenről szól leet tehát
itt kezdve attól hogy
hogy van-e egy jól működő nem tudom
online ügyintézési lehetőség az adott
városban hogy lehet-e a különböző
intézményeknél online foglalni hogy
vannak-e olyan digitális eszközeink amik
mondjuk a a forgalmat a tömeg
közlekedést a parkolást segítik hogy az
iskolákban tudjuk-e használni oktatásban
ezeket a
a a digitalizáció és így tovább tehát
azt gondolom hogy ez ilyen szempontból
viszont nem egy különálló
különálló terület hanem ez gyakorlatilag
ezek a digitalizációval kapcsolatos
elemek ezek részét kell képezzék nem
csak a digitális stratégiának hanem
gyakorlatilag minden más stratégiának
tehát hogyha van és jó esetben kellene
legyen annak a annak a régiónak vagy
városnak van
egy gazdasági stratégiája egy oktatási
stratégiája egy egészségügyi sport és
így tovább kulturális ezeknek mind
részét kéne kellene képezzék ezek a ezek
az elemek és akkor ilyen szempontból egy
digitális stratégiának a a szerepe
tulajdonképpen az hogy ezeket valahogy
egybefogja és facilitálja ezeket a
fejlesztéseket amiket különböző
területeken területre jellemző
stratégiák keretében meghatározva
különböző területeken kellene aztán
aztán alkalmazni te ez ezekben részt
fogsz venni ezeknek a ennek a digitális
stratégiának a a kivitelezésében
igen tehát a amire akkor igen a a még
visszatérve a másik részére a
kérdésednek hogy az én közéleti vagy
politikai szerepvállalásom hát én amit a
amit igazából a választási kampány során
is amit elmondtam hogy én abban tudok
leginkább hozzáadni ehhez a a
történethez amiben ugye tapasztalatom is
van és ez két dolog ugye a elsősorban ez
a amiről beszélünk ez az informatika it
illetve az oktatás elsősorban ugye a
felső oktatás hogy értelemszerűen
ezen a vonalon szeretnék tevékenykedni
és mint mondtam már itt a abban a
úgymond szerencsés helyzetben vagyunk
ilyen szempontból itt ennek már vannak
előzényet itt már volt egy it
fejlesztési program úgyhogy itt ilyen
szempontból első
körben az az nagyon fontos hogy ezt ezt
ezt megerősítsük példáuly hogy tudjunk
ezekkel ez ezzel még úgymond szintet
lépni és
és igen ezen kívül tehát hogy hogy hogy
nagyon sok helyen már a jelenlegi tervek
között is megjelenik ez a ez a
digitalizációs vonal és ez nagyon helyes
és nagyon jó hogy megjelenik mert pont
ez kell ahhoz amiről beszélgettünk az
elején hogy lépést lépést tudjunk
tartani és
és igen a a csapat azt tervezi hogy hogy
hogy hogy hogy tesz is azért hogy ezek
összejöjjenek ezek a dolgok tehát akkor
gyakorlatilag megismétlem eddig is volt
tevékenység eddig is volt egy vízió ami
mentén haladtok a következő négy év
ilyen szempontból nem azon fog
változtatni hogy most lesz-e vagy nem
lesz mert csak folytatjátok tovább talán
gyorsítva gyorsított ütemben fog tudni
megvalósulni feltételezem azt hogy
ekkora többséget szerzett a a az
önkormányzati testület meg maga a
polgármesternek a személye is egy olyan
valaki aki átlátja a digitális
stratégiának a fontosságát talán ezeket
hoznám mint érva mellett hogy hogy talán
talán egy nagyobb sikerünk lesz a
követke ő négy évben ilyen szempontból
látványosabb lesz nagyon nagyon reméljük
hogy hogy hogy így lesz és hogyan tudnak
neked segíteni az emberek ebben a a ebbe
a küzdelembe nagyon hallgató kedvéért
mondom az elmúlt négy évben sokat
beszélgettünk erről hihetetlenül komplex
hihetetlenül komplex magának a a tehát
egy ilyen stratégiát kidolgozni aminek
ennyi oldala van és ennyi minden ami
megakadályozhatja és kell legyen egy
politikai oldala ez a furcsa hogy hogy
azt mondhatnánk hogy hogy nem szükséges
a politika de önmagában a cégek nem
elegendő ahhoz hogy összefogjanak és és
és létrehozzák talán de de mindenképpen
azt látom hogy szükséges egy egész
városnak a stratégiájába beépíteni és a
városvezetés is egyet kell értsen ezzel
és szükséges persze akkor a a privát
szektor de szükséges az oktatás tehát
gyakorlatilag ez így tényleg
összpontosul így a te személyedben
emiatt is látom azt hogy egy neked
kiemelt szereped lehet ebben hogyha ha
ha te is egyetérrtesz hogyan tudnak
neked az emberek ebben segíteni itt azt
kell azért mondjam hogy ez eddig sem egy
személyes történet volt tehát hogy hogy
hogy hogy szerencsére sokan vannak vagy
többen vannak azok akik akik akik eddig
is részt vettek ezekben a folyamatokban
nélkülünk nem is működhetett volna tehát
azért szerencsére ennek a programnak
eddig is amiről beszélgettünk hogy eddig
is voltak szép eredményei felsoroltunk
jó néhányat tehát középiskolásoknak
egyetemistáknak felnőtteknek képzés
konferencia rendezvény rendezvények
rendezvények és így tovább tehát nagyon
és mindezáltal ugye tényleg elértük azt
hogy láthatóbbá vált a a a helyi szektor
és
és azt látjuk hogy hogy ezáltal a hely
helyi cégek tudtak növekedni tehát ugy
átlagosan nagyjából úgy látjuk hogy egy
a mióta a program indulása óta egy olyan
300%-os növekedést tudtak átlagosan
produkálni ami mellé még bejött az hogy
megjelentek új cégek vagy új
kirendeltségek akik szintén tudtak itt a
régióban rensüni úgyhogy ennek ennek
szerencsére már
vannak eredményei az elég sok nehézség
ellenére is szép eredményei de ez eddig
sem egy egy személyes egy személyes
történet volt tehát ez ez több embernek
v sok embernek a
a munkájára szükség szükség volt már
eddig is és ez ez ugyanígy lesz a a
továbbiakban is
tehát azt remélem én hogy hogy ezek még
úgymond felgyorsulnak vagy szintte
tudnak lépni ezek a kezdeményezések van
nagyon sok további
terve a a csapatnak amelyeket
akkor ez ezekre az az eddigi
eredményekre alapozva nagyon remélem
hogy hogy el fogunk érni és nagyon
remélem hogy azok
a hát nem csak személyekre gondolok
hanem akár szervezetekre és
intézményekre is akikkel eddig is együtt
működtünk azok továbbra is
ott lesznek ugyanúgy ahogy ott voltak
eddig és még hatékonyabban fogunk tudni
dolgozni együtt azáltal hogy hogy
hogy van egy
közös mert nem tudom akarat és és
rálátás is ezekre a történetekre vagy
ezeknek a fontosságára milyen új
terveitek vannak vagy terveink vannak
ugyanis az én cégem is része ennek a
klaszternek hát ugye régi új tervek is
vannak ugye itt szerintem itt
itt neked nem kell mondanom de t lehet
hogy a hallgatóságnak igen hogy itt már
hossz tehát több év óta beszélgettünk
például a mesteri program üüm
elindításáról ez hogy halad
hát
erről majd lehet hogy két hónap
megkérdezzél tehát még még még ott van a
levegőben még mindig tehát igen hogy
hogy az idén elindulhat-e ez a kérdés
idén biztos hogy nem tehát ez ugye ez
ősszelindítható program ez elég régóta
tiszta hogy ahhoz hogy te tehát mesterít
csak az egyetemit anível párhuzamosan
tudsz
indítani ahhoz hogy meghirdetődjön
felvételi lebonyolít le legyen
bonyolítva ahhoz még sok minden kell ez
eddig is nyilvánvaló volt tehát át kell
meg kell legyen a a hely az
infrastruktúra be kell legyen rendezve
az akkreditáció honnak ez előfeltétele
mert nem fognak neked egy programot
akkreditálni addig ameddig nem tudod a a
helyszínt biztosítani meg kell hirdetni
le kell bonyolítani a felvételit
gyakorlatilag a nyárig tehát ez
2000 25 az indítása ez ez már egy jó
ideje nyilvánvaló volt de én nagyon
remélem hogy arra ezt meg tudjuk lépni
ugyan akkor remélem hogy már most tát
itt az elején mondom először ezeket a
ezek nem is igazából új tervek hanem már
régebbi terveket remélemés remélem most
már sikerül elindítani a posztgraduális
képzésnek is szeret nk a jövő évben egy
új évfolyamát úy ismét udvarhelyen
elindítani remélhetőleg egy nagyobb
regionális lefedéssel ugye most is
jellemző most az a mostani évfolyam az
ők szentgyörgyön végeznek most
szeptemberben de ott is vannak udvarhei
diákok vásárhelyről érkező diákok
próbálnánk ezt ezt itt itt itt
stabilizálni
a digitális
székelyföld konferencia jó esé fog
visszatérni hamarosan a
a városunkba ugyanúgy a
ezeket a rendezvényeket digitális kaláka
ugye a hekaton ami minden évben
valamilyen témaköré ugye az idén pont
ilyen kulturális témakörben szerveztük
jövőben ugyanúgy tervezzük megszervezni
valószínű egy más témakörben amit most
még nem mondanék itt el de ez ez is ez
is hamarosan ki fog alakulni digitál
iskalák az egyetemistákat illetve
szakmai bléeket összefogó a informatikus
találkozó tehát ezeket ugyanúgy
tervezzük megszervezni mentorprogramok
amikről már már beszélgettünk tehát ezek
olyan olyan olyan történetek amik amik
igazából nem újak tehát hogy ezekről
ezekről már eddig is beszélgettünk de
ezt követően egy következő lépésben
szeretnénk hogyha ezek egy úgymond
szintet is tudnának lépni meg ki lehetne
terjeszteni ezt tehát ez a vagy ezeket
ez a
mentorprogram koncepció ez nem egy olyan
tört ami csak az informatika
informatikával szoftverfejlesztésen
működik ezt más területeken is hasonlóan
lehetne alkalmazni hogyha már egyszer
van egy kiásott út egy igen és például
ugyaníy az egyetemi
programok nem gondolom azt hogy
rövidtávon itt teljes alapképzéseket
tudunk indítani a vagy vagy egyáltalán
ez most
időszerű lenne a értelemszerűen az
egyetemekkel együttműködve de igen azt
gondolom hogy el kellene és el is tudunk
indítani ilyen ridebb lefutású
flexibilisebben szervezhető
posztgraduális képzéseket mesteri
programokat satöbbi satöbbi amik megint
hozzá tudnak járulni ahhoz hogy akkor
alapképzés már az alapképzésü befejezése
után a fiatalok vissza tudjanak jönni és
itthon tudjanak tovább tanulni ezzel
együtt akár itthon szakmában
elhelyezkedni és ezek a programok nem
csak az info területén tudnak működni
ezek más területeken is hasonlóak
elindíthatóak illetve ezek között lehet
egy
és kellene is legyen egy egy egy
kapcsolat adnak tehát mondjuk el tudok
képzelni egy hasonló mentorprogramot
mondjuk kimondottan termékfejlesztés
irányába ahol már nem csak
informatikusok vesznek részt hanem
jönnek más például közgázról akár akár
hallgatok és hallgatók és akkor akkor
lefedik annak nem csak a fejlesztési
aspektusát annak a történetnek hanem az
egyéb sszel marketinggel egyebekkel
kapcsolatos aspektusokat is tehát hogy
ezek a programok hogyha ezeket sikerül
amikről az imént beszéltünk megerősíteni
akkor ezek gyakorlatilag egy alapot
szolgáltathatnak utána sok minden
sok minden egyébnek hasonló programok
elindításának más területeken is azt
hiszem ez zárszónak tökéletes nagyon
szurkolok nektek ez egy nagyon jó
beszélgetés volt köszönöm a az időd és
és üljünk le majd egy pár hónap múlva
talán egy fél év év múlva hogy lássuk
hogy hogyan alakult az it cllasernek a
tevékenysége én személyesen nagyon
szurkolok ennek a mesterképzésnek mert
pont emiatt hogy hy a diákok akik az
alapképzést elvégezték legyen egy
alternatíva hogy hazaköltözve egyszerre
tudjanak munkába állni esetleg mellette
egy mesterképzést elvégezni és és hogy
lássák érezzék a saját bőrükön hogy egy
kisvárosban mennyire jó
lenni és mennyi lehetőség van egyre több
úgyhogy köszönöm szépen kares hogy
eljöttél és egyed tudtunk beszélgetni én
köszönöm szépen a meghívást és a
lehetőséget és a hallgatóknak a kedvéért
az it classernek a a honlapját majd a a
leírásba csatolni fogjuk meg minden
egyéb
olyan szükséges információt amit te
fontosnak tartaszt majd mindenképpen ott
összegezni fogjuk hogy mindenki el tudja
érni szép napot mindenkinek köszönjük
szépen és köszönöm szépen karz még
egyszer kösz szépen szép napot
s ha tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz
fel kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a vekker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért valamint a bizalomtők
ne a támogatásért nékületek nem jöhetett
volna ez létre